for over 80 years
amazing storytellers from different
mediums including comic books tv films
games and more i've created the vast
ever-changing multiverse of stories
worlds and characters that have come to
define dc these iconic worlds have
become a part of our own culture gotham
city metropolis central city atlantis
the mascara and the iconography for dc's
heroes images like the bat symbol the
batmobile logos like the s shield and
the lantern are immediately recognized
worldwide the classic superheroes have
inspired and the super villains have
entertained generations of fans across
the globe that is who we're here to
celebrate today
you the dc fans the passion and the
commitment you bring to the world of dc
is what has kept it going for over 80
years and will keep us going for many
more and the future of dc is brighter
than ever we will have something for
everyone surprising and delighting fans
who have been on the journey with us all
along but also inspiring a whole new
generation to carry the torch that is
the power of dc what powers do you see
is you
sit back for the next few hours and
enjoy as we celebrate the past showcase
the present and preview what the future
holds
welcome to dc fandom welcome to d.c
welcome to dc fandom welcome to dc
fandom welcome
to dc fandom welcome to dc fandom
the most powerful force in the universe
is a story
[Music]
a story shapes hearts and minds
withstands the test of time
and changes the way
we see the world
a story turns characters into icons
moments
into memories
and shows us that heroes come in many
forms
and in this fight for truth justice and
a better tomorrow
our story
is just beginning
you guys might want to hold on
[Music]
this is gonna be the start of something
huge
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
[Music]
who am i think there's something he
needs to show me
[Music]
the decent universe
will never be the same
[Applause]
i'm vengeance
[Music]
hey everyone i am tiffany smith and
welcome to the much anticipated fan
inspired worldwide event dc fandom did
you hear that music
pretty cool right well dc fandom now has
its very own score by composer blake
neely if you're a credits watcher like
me you'll probably recognize his name
from such terrific dc tv shows like you
know the flash supergirl legends of
tomorrow and so many more you will be
hearing a lot more of flake's incredible
score throughout the show now if you
were here last year then you might have
an idea of the kind of awesomeness that
is about to come your way huge reveals
exclusive content and a few big
surprises there is so much that i
couldn't possibly do this on my own so
of course we put together a pretty super
team of co-hosts as well as celebrity
hosts that you're gonna get to hang out
with all day so let's say hello to a few
of them right now starting with our
brazilian friends
hello super fans i'm marico borgo it is
so good to be back at dc fandom this is
alina ginis
fantastic
hi friends
my name is geno killiamore and i
couldn't be more excited to share what
dc has in store for you
[Music]
boom throughout the fanatic terrier i'm
here
dc is doing it up big this year
hola mundo i'm gabby cam and all of us
here are just as excited as you are to
be back at dc fandom so sit back get
comfy and get ready for the biggest
celebration of all things tv
[Music]
g'day mates i'm jaden rodriguez today we
gather from all around the globe to
celebrate our love for dc comics and the
stars and creators who bring them to
life
this is warner brothers and dc's way of
saying thank you to the fans for your
loyalty dedication and passion for the
characters and the stories in the dc
universe later in the show you're not
going to want to miss this the much
anticipated new trailer for the batman
and gamers get ready for the gotham
knights game javicia leslie flies into
action as batman and we're also diving
in deep with my man jason momoa and
getting a mouthful from king shark and
harley quinn shazam zachary levi
enlightens us on the fury of the gods
we're taking the fast lane with the
flash plus naomi doom patrol peacemaker
and some surprises with so much to share
let's kick things off in a really big
way with one of the biggest stars to
ever rock the dc universe
black adam
[Music]
i've never seen the likes of it before
having done james bond for 10 years four
films
nothing compares to this
i play hawkman
cyclone
adam smasher
dr fate
leading the whole
charge is dwayne johnson
he's more brutal
uncompromising
fueled by the depths of his pain
he's black adam
black adam
[Music]
hey dc fandom and hello to everyone
watching around the world i am so
excited right now to be here and to talk
to you about the man in black himself
black adam
now as you guys know this character this
film this universe has been a gigantic
passion project of mine for a very long
time and i have worked so hard work
these hands these calluses my fingers to
the bone on this project because it's
the kind of project that i know comes
along once in a lifetime and the truth
is
i was born to play
black adam
now we've just started the
post-production process which is so
exciting and the film has without
question some of the biggest action
sequences i have ever been a part of and
i am so proud and excited of our
incredible team who are working away to
create breathtaking holy scenes
that i know you're really going to love
now even though we're still working away
this is dc fandom so i felt like i had
to bring you guys just a little
something special now you know me guys
and you know i always like to say that
you the audience the people you guys are
my number one boss so i got together
with my director jama caletsera and we
put together a little glimpse of one of
the opening scenes of the movie when
black adam is first revealed
now what you're going to see here
is why the hierarchy of power
in the dc universe
is about to change
i hope you enjoy this very first look at
the man in black himself
black adam
[Music]
she's out
[Applause]
what a way to start the show dwayne
johnson was honestly born to play black
adam am i right and if you've been
following him on instagram he's
definitely been working hard to make
sure his body looks just right for this
role once again if you're just joining
us i'm tiffany smith and you know how i
mentioned earlier we were going to have
some celebrity hosts for the show well
let's not waste any time and bring one
of them in right now real quick
i know you were hoping to see this guy
tvs flash aka barry allen aka grant
gustin in the house how you doing grant
thank you so much for joining us from
set thank you tiffany i wouldn't miss
experiencing dc fandom with all the fans
who are watching today yeah i am so
excited for it as well but we are here
to talk with you about the flash and we
have to talk about the end of season
seven what was it like seeing nora again
and meeting bart is it a weird feeling
for you to talk to your future kids who
are basically like the same age as you
yeah it has always been a little weird
to play the father role with actors who
are essentially the same age as me um
but it's you know and for barry it was
obviously a very emotional reunion with
nora and and to meet bart for the first
time
but i've you know for me it's just fun
like i've always loved working with
jessica uh who plays nora and
you know she's so sweet and so talented
and um
i'd never met or worked with jordan
before but we have a lot of
mutual friends and we had a lot of fun
together
so yeah it was it was a blast having
both of them on set okay so at dc fandom
last year you touched on something the
fans and you have been really hoping to
see for years tell us about this
obsession of yours with the gold boots
on the flash
it's less of an obsession and more
i've it's just always been the final
element that i think has been missing
from our suits you know and um i've
loved all the versions of of the flash
suit that we've had on the show but the
suit that we have now in particular i
think is kind of the closest to a lot of
the different iterations you see in the
comic books with the exception of those
gold boots and i've always felt like the
gold boots would just be the nice final
touch now although i'd love to keep the
combo going we've gotta toss this over
to where grant's tv wife is standing by
[Music]
thanks grant it is so great to be here
talking to dc super fans my role as
reporter iris west allen on the flash
has given me the skills needed to
properly introduce dc fandom's news
flashes the time has finally come grant
and barry allen finally get the gold
boots for season eight of the flash here
is the first official look at the new
costume
look at you smiling how excited are you
to finally have the boots yeah i'm very
excited that fans get to see the first
look at the boots um they'll probably be
running around vancouver in them so i'm
really excited you guys got to see a
first look at the boots thanks so much
grant i'm looking forward to seeing you
in action in those coveted gold boots
but i know it's gonna be awesome on the
show and hey it's been fun kicking it
here with you
yeah sorry dad jokes they're just gonna
keep coming coming up we've got some
never before seen footage from the
suicide squad game aquaman the lost
kingdom harley quinn and
all the batmans or batman you know what
i mean now not only do we here in the dc
fandom want to know what you out there
in the fan verse think but we wanted to
know what you can do you send in the
best of your best cosplay in fanart and
here is just a sample of some of the
amazing talent out there in the dc
fandom
[Music]
so
aloha dc fandom i apologize for the
four-year wait oh my gosh we've been
here since 2017. i'm very proud of the
sequel because it's tackling a lot of
issues environmentally stakes are higher
and i'm just excited because i had a big
part in my boy james you know
check it out i'm excited for you to see
it the tides are changing this is the
tour the tabs are changing
like the comic book the world of aquaman
is so big
and so rich it's epic it's huge it's
colorful the world is at stake i'm super
excited to be back making the sequel i
have so much invested into it i love
this character i love what it represents
there's nothing that i've ever been a
part of that's like this people are
going to be in for a treat when aquaman
2 comes out they're going to get a movie
that's more mature
but yet still retain it's fun
to give the audience something different
something new that they haven't seen
before the success of that movie as the
biggest dc movie of all time shows what
james wan and his team were able to do
and in this second film we have turned
the dials up to 11. it has the action
the fun the heart
action
superheroes and super villains have
entertained generations of fans across
the globe good you got it we put that in
the movie
to play around with this cast again it's
quite a trip we're having a blast this
movie's a lot of fun
i think fans are gonna be very happy
i think james is really excited to go
all out
this is an exciting thing we better get
to a little bit of action
it's gonna be a fun adventure like it
was the first time
just better
we see that black bente is still seeking
his vengeance to try and kill aquaman
that's gonna be something that's
exciting for the audience something for
them to be swept up into the world of
aquaman again
but uh kicks my ass
it's a globetrotting story
we visit so many different worlds this
movie isn't afraid to embrace its
fantasy and go on this magical journey i
think it's gonna be really awesome
hmm aquaman now there is a cool gig i
could get used to that surf and turf
lifestyle swimming in the day carrying a
gigantic pitchfork at night with some
facial hair all over my face hmm so you
could imagine my excitement when i heard
i was cast in the next aquaman i was
like hey hold up what about jason mamawa
how did he take the news
apparently he was extremely happy for me
he thought i would be the perfect fish
in hbo max's upcoming aquaman king of
atlantis animated miniseries here's a
splash of what's to come
[Music]
he is aquaman and he just became king of
atlantis thank you
[Music]
is there a different throne we could
know
and the fate of his people
of his home
of all the world is in his hands that's
right yeah no pressure
join aquaman for the undersea adventure
of a lifetime
aquaman king of atlantis three-part
special event now streaming
huh
ocean master
[Music]
hey ocean master you out there anywhere
uh i think he's gone
[Music]
so be it
farewell my brother still got your
trident oh that little fruit i hate this
we're supposed to be getting revenge on
him not saving him it's fine it'll still
be the same mission get ocean master
punch him and bring the trident back to
atlantis
yeah but it's less fun now true but if
you don't bring ocean master back
everyone's definitely gonna think you
100 killed him and i won't even get to
that's the worst part
where do you think they went i don't
know i have to ask for help from the
only people who don't think i'm a total
joke people who are not people
people who save fish
fish
i'm talking to the fish yeah i'm talking
to the fish
like this one that one her him or maybe
even this i shed down the kind of so no
no it intercepts their brains they shoot
it back to me
and it goes inside my face they tell me
their thoughts and fears they tell me
secret things they all love me and i
love them because i am their king
[Music]
hello mates jaden rodriguez in the dc
fandom wow look at this place
after that last segment i've got that
song talking to the fish stuck in my
head
and if you can't get enough of this tune
well you can listen to it right now on
spotify
i'd like to introduce to you two legends
in the comic book and entertainment
world milestone media partner reggie
hudlin and milestone media co-founder
dennis cowan and a familiar face from
the dc family echo kellum
take a look all right hey everybody i am
echo kellum and first of all i hope you
guys are having a blast at dc fandom
2021 now we have a really great program
in store for you guys today and to get
things started i would like to introduce
you all to two legends in the comic book
entertainment world milestone media
partner reggie hutlin and milestone
media co-founder
dennis cowan
sounded claps oh yeah that's like a
applause everywhere everywhere
now uh first of all i'm so happy to be
able to interview you guys static shock
was such a huge thing for me growing up
and whatnot but for those of us who
might not know could you please tell us
what milestone and milestone media is
milestone was founded in uh actually
found in the 90s
by myself with with derek dingle michael
davis and and dwayne mcduffie the late
great dwayne mcduffie people of color
underrepresented in this industry
especially i mean in the entertainment
industry in general but especially in
comic books so uh we all got together
with the idea of doing comic books for
creators of color uh the best way to do
that was to get together and to create a
line of books that would reflect and
represent our culture so that's what we
did we started with a book called static
and we did a book haul hardware
icon and rocket was the next one
followed by the blood syndicate and we
launched in 1992 to great acclaim it was
very successful and kind of changed the
game in in comics in a in in a major way
and suddenly
people who were underrepresented now
have representation it was a big deal
and it was a lot of fun to do but it was
a it was a lot at that time you guys
have already made big strides since the
fandom 2020 uh panel with the launch of
static season one and icon and rocket
season one and hardware season one
limited series so what's the feedback
been like from fans new nodes seeing
these characters in their renaissance
it's really been great um
people were like about time you were
taking too long
but now you're here you're living up to
expectations it's a lot of commentary
from a lot of different types of people
they love the art they're like oh my god
i love this kind of you know black anime
style that's you know you guys didn't
get stuck in the past you kept it
relevant you kept it edgy to what's now
they really love the dynamic between
static and his dad i relate to it a lot
as a reader i'm like wow that's like me
and my father i try to be like that with
my son
it's great stories but it's in that mass
strong tradition of what is stories
you're not going to read at any other
company milestone is a unique style of
storytelling which delivers quality
superhero action because the founders
were all the top creators in the
business then and now
and at the same time
really speaking to where people of color
are and what our or what our challenges
are in the 21st century oh that's
awesome that's very cool and i know you
were talking about um
the universe and whatnot so like well
comic book fans they obviously love the
notion of a connected universe well we
see some of the characters from season
one titles begin to appear in each
other's books oh yeah oh yeah yeah
that's definitely that's definitely
that's definitely part of the plan i
mean we're working so far ahead we
actually already know
how season one is going to end and how
you know things might advance from there
so
we can tell you with all confidence to
the fans out there that yes
the characters will appear in each
other's books and meet each other and
there is an interconnected
you know dakota verse
you know milestone universe within these
books so yeah that's one of the things
that we've been focusing on and doing it
um what else is in the works what's
coming up
well uh we have a lot of stuff coming up
yeah all these books have been really
successful so you'll be seeing season
two of icon and hardware and static
and uh uh and um icon and rocket
but there's a book that everyone's been
like
yo what's going on we're gonna bring it
back what's our favorite we like that
other stuff but yeah no come without
things so
blood syndicate which is
i mean a shocking number of people's
favorite book from the original
milestone line will be coming back
and a lot of people have been shocked
about how hard
the uh
the moonlight of books have been blood
syndicate
that's all i'm saying could you and
could you guys talk about uh a little
bit of the uh
com uh the compendium that's coming out
the uh the milestone compendium that's
having like
all the old comics or something like
that coming in right yeah again we're
trying to give people what they want so
many fans have been like reg we're so
excited you're bringing new books back
but you know my mom threw out my books
or i moved and there was some water
damage so i lost all my original copies
or i was too young back then but i want
to catch up with the old school as well
as the new school so
it's a giant book you know it's gonna be
huge a thousand three hundred pages of
material
soft cover 1 300 pages of of collecting
um the first runs of hardware and icon
rockets static like everything and this
is volume one i keep hearing this aspect
that you really want to bring the media
back into milestone media right can you
talk to us about some of those potential
projects that might be existing outside
of the comic book realm they're not mike
they're they're they're real they're
happening we've got two movie projects
in development right now the script that
randy mckinnon is writing for the live
action feature film version of static is
you know he's hard at work right now
we're going to be getting that soon so
live action static shock is a real thing
that's in the works
you know warner brothers is excited
about it we're excited about it michael
b jordan's excited about it michael b
jordan's producing the movie with us
here's the new announcement uh that no
one knows yet this is fandom breaking
news
which is
uh the first milestone animated feature
film is now in the works you know we
just had an amazing writer
and if you guys have been reading
hardware you know how dope he is as a
writer brandon thomas brandon thomas has
been hired to write our screenplay for
our animated feature
and uh in conjunction with warner
brothers and we're very excited about
that that's going to be
a massive project with more than one
character yeah um this is going to be
the thing that milestone fans have been
really dreaming about for a long time
and we're happy to give it to them
finally so
you know not only we're doing live
action we're doing animation yeah and
we're bringing it so yeah so
compendium
all the classic old school
um
milestone material
we've got uh the black history month
book that's in the works
and two movies in the works wow i mean
you guys are dropping some major kernels
and awesome news but
but i'm hearing that there is some news
that you guys are kind of holding back
some really big news
can you guys tell everyone about how
milestone is working to create the next
wave of great superhero storytellers
we're doing a program that we're so
excited about it's in conjunction with
dc comics dc has a program called ng dc
next generation dc it's a large program
we're doing a part of that program
called the milestone initiative we're
partnering with ally
and
they're working with us
to bring the next generation
of comic book artists writers colorists
editors letters
and all aspects of the comic book
industry to comics
you know there's a lot of talented
people the same way you look at the
black presence of music the black
presence in film and television is now
to have that it's time for us to have
that same impact on the comic industry
you know pioneers like dennis like
dwayne like cal baker like christopher
priest you know these are the folks who
just you know they had a machete and
then the machete broke then he had a
butter knife but they kept cutting their
way through the woods and they cleared a
path and now we're saying come on let's
go right right because none of it all of
it's meaningless unless
there are people behind you
who are also doing the same thing and
even better from that path that you made
so that that's why this is very
important to us and and we're very
excited about our our relationship
you know with dc and ally so what we
want everyone to do is if you have
interest in any aspect of this business
you know in terms of comic books in
terms of animation all these different
fields apply to the program yes we won't
take any everybody but we're going to
take the you know the best of the bunch
and you know we'll put you
in seminars and training sessions with
some of the most talented people in our
field you're going to hear from the best
of the best and we're going to groom you
to be the next generation of superstars
we need you yeah well i'll just say like
as a
young creator
this is like such amazing news the fact
you guys are helping representation in
this field it's critical and
pocs and lgbtqia
uh groups will be very
this is just really good work and i'm
sure dwayne is
smiling from heaven but just how you
guys are honoring his legacy and just
continuing to do some really great work
that's really awesome that's really dope
very happy to hear that well i want to
thank my guests milestone exact reggie
hutlin and dennis cowan for joining us
today and i want to thank you for being
a part of our dc fandom 2021 be sure to
keep watching for more news fun and
excitement as dc fandom continues
what an amazing opportunity for our fans
a special shout out to ally for backing
that program
the next segment is one of my favorites
because it celebrates our fans and here
is just a sample of the amazing talent
out there in the dc fandom
[Music]
wow such incredible talent out there
and i hear that jim lee will be
announcing the winners at the end of the
show so stay tuned to see if you've been
chosen
now back over to you candice for some
more breaking news
[Music]
dc and webtoon recently partnered to
bring our iconic superheroes and super
villains to new and old fans kicking off
the collaboration with batman wayne
family adventures a smash hit inspired
by the fandom around the bat family all
your fan favorite characters like
stephanie brown cassandra kane barbara
gordon and duke thomas will have their
own featured episodes and arcs in this
hilarious slice of life series only
available on webtoon ndc fans can expect
more amazing dc webtoon originals coming
soon check out this exclusive sneak peek
[Music]
still to come peacemaker gotham knights
and the batman
[Music]
hello it's me again international
superstar and superhero flula borg now
as some of you may know i actually got
my start in green lantern issue number
173 in 1984
well actually i was just two years old
then because i'm talking of course about
my super dope comic character javelin
you know the one with the huge
rod yeah that's the one as you saw
earlier i also play a hilarious animated
fish in the aquaman king of atlantis
series you just saw boy i am so
multi-talented watch out
two things i can do
anyway over the years javelin and his
impressive collection of pointy poles
has popped up in many different
scenarios but i gotta say i'm really
digging where he ended up no i don't
mean dead but with that infamous team of
super villains the suicide squad and for
those of you who are worried about
javelin's fate ah fear not i'm here to
tell you today that javelin is still
alive and spoiler alert will be applying
to head up the justice league after
their fate is revealed in the huge new
video game suicide squad kill the
justice league
you are about to get a sneaky peaky so
don't go anywhere because it is going to
be a massive and we know when it comes
to the universe of dc video games and
javelins
size matters
let's take a look
all of you are the worst of the worst of
the worst
still
you're good at what you do
even if what you do is far from good
welcome to task force ads
let me take a look at you
a muscle head
a nut job
something that offends my eyes
and a homeless person
[Music]
you're perfect
just checking we're all seeing that
thing right this has one way ticket
written all over it
what the hell have you sent us youtube
it's a bloody war zone out here eyes up
people congratulations
for that you're the first asset to make
it into metropolis alive
[Music]
i was just about to do that
task force x
your new mission
is to kill the justice league
[Music]
raise your hand if taking on the justice
league is the worst idea you've ever
heard
i kind of signed
[Music]
what did you out would happen you'd
crawl out of yourselves swoop in save
the day
which superheroes did you say you were
undead
[Music]
he's not gonna make it
the penguin is in flight repeat the
penguin is in
flight then let's clip his wings
oh my god he's gotten up hitting him
again
he's ran out the door
somebody stop him
did not get him a waller
waller blow up his head
[Music]
wow
definitely don't want to get on amanda
waller's bad side
maybe it's a good thing javelin is not
in the suicide squad kill the justice
league game
still
of course in the movie i was hoping i'd
come back to life in the end credit
sequence but no such luck maybe that'll
happen in the vhs version of the suicide
squad double fingers double-crossed
let's do this i mean look john cena gets
a spin-off series but not me flula borg
i'm delicious where's my show the
suicide squad is fast becoming a huge
franchise for dc with comic books huge
movies the games of video like you just
saw not storing me apparently spin-off
series also not starring erode and music
videos fine i'll make my own i have a
phone anyway if you go to the clubs like
i do with me and my best friend's squad
friend king shark you'll know this next
song is all the rave
give me those glow sticks yeah don't
give them to him
blue
[Music]
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
we're gonna die
you're gonna die
[Music]
just try to get that song out of your
brains now baby sharks
of course i'm happy to be a part of such
an amazing squad and that includes you
the fans thank you for supporting
everything the suicide squad we haught
you i think it goes like that and i know
i'm not alone when i say that i have
proof for you here is a very special
message from all my squad buddies to
share check me out i mean check check it
out it's it's this week i'm not a
narcissist
i donate
from the entire suicide squad from the
bottom of our hearts
we thank you none of this would be
possible without you you are the reason
why we do what we do as a director i
feel truly blessed we are so incredibly
grateful and lucky to have you
wow
i don't know what to say guys it's
so unexpected i just feel so loved i
don't have a
speech prepared or anything but let me
just say that uh
you are so so welcome john john john
we're not thanking you mate we're
thanking all the fans oh yeah
yeah
right
i mean of course they're the fans right
they
know i like to joke around which is
exactly what that was it's a joke sure
john what john means is that he would
also like to thank you our amazing fans
thank you
love you guys
[Music]
okay you guys know that was a joke the
suicide squad would be absolutely
nowhere without the support of the fans
you guys love these characters as much
if not more than we do
and i truly want to thank you for your
passion
flula man i'm i'm sorry bro javelin
would have made a great character for a
spin-off
you know what maybe we can see about
getting involved somewhere down the line
on peacemaker i mean no promises
james gunn created this whole thing for
hbo max and you know he has a vision all
worked out but we'll see what we can do
and if you want to hear more what's in
store for peacemaker you can join james
myself and my amazing castmates for some
additional insights
hey everybody john cena here on the set
of peacemakers
every time you were shooting he went
why am i doing this
they said she couldn't get a job
up
oh hi
23andme says i might be 26 percent
asshat i know my last name is smith
that's a generic name the reason
it's smith is because we came over as
asshats and i had to change it on ellis
island
[Music]
hey everybody i'm james gunn today we're
talking all things peacemaker of course
i'm joined by my behind the scenes
partners in crime executive producers
peter safran and matt miller and our
fantastic cast peacemaker himself john
cena danielle brooks who plays character
of my own making leota adebayo jennifer
holland and steve agee emilia harcourt
and john economos and chucklewuji is
clemson mirn and finally freddie stroma
who is our vigilante so guys let's get
into it it goes without saying i miss
you guys it's great to see you all
john were you surprised when peter
called you up and said hey you know
we're thinking about doing a peacemaker
tv series i was surprised but uh
man i i i was more than ready and i was
more than excited and i'm glad we got
the opportunity freddie for you you came
in and you're playing the oddest
character of everybody vigilante adrian
chase and you're not that odd yeah no
i'm
so
pretty vanilla
i i love it i i really like as soon as
as soon as i started reading the sides i
was just like oh i i really like this
character um and he has just that kind
of you know
a really fun relationship with
peacemaker and obviously working with
john was just incredible i've seen
freddie but for how many of the rest of
you are you hearing him talk with a
british accent for the first time oh me
yeah and i'm i'm like my brain is melted
i can't believe it
so uh danielle why don't you tell us a
little bit about your your character in
general who she is and what's her story
this is all new to her you know and so
she's coming in
very green she used to work with animals
and now she's been thrown into this
completely different world you brought
her to life you really did and you do
inhabit a role in this very special way
and it was just so fun to see you
flow for harcourt
uh
her relationship with adebayo this new
member of the team that's coming in and
that harcourt does not trust
um
it was
something really unexpected for me
when i met danielle and i i literally
could not hate her like she is just the
most
she's the most lovable warm wonderful
person the uh the sisterhood of harcourt
and adebayo is a wonderful thing to see
it feels like that's part of sorry james
says no go headshot the first day we
shot at least i shot in john cena's
trailer and it was the scene where we
all the team meet john cena and
danielle you made her continuously
improvise being nervous and she would
i mean that improvisation as every there
were tears running down people's eyes
and it went on and on and danielle was
put on the spot and the things that were
coming out of her and to the point where
off-camera steve aj just had to get his
camera out and film it i was just gonna
say it reminds me of how often
working with um with steve you'd uh you
know be in a scene and you'd look over
behind the camera and
there's a.g
filming you this is like my first day
with the cat like all the cats too and
steve a.g is recording everybody's
laughing john cena's holding character
so he's making me nervous everything it
was crazy but it was one of the things i
would never ever ever forget it's okay
if you do forget it because i have it
all on video
i freaking love
everything about your six seven self
however tall you are
that's about right
freddy was such a warm spirit to come
into the space as well like you know
even though he was new he jumped right
in fearlessly and worked with us and
jakuti is the real deal from day one
you're just like oh my gosh he elevated
all of us to bring our best so it's been
really great working work you know
getting to work with everybody and you
just really made a girl's dream come
true to get to tell this story with you
all this is not a world that a person
like me normally gets to be a part of at
all to have the action portion and also
the depth of of a person i am so
thankful for you i love you i just think
you're the greatest
although you know i'm surprised you did
you did give chuck so many uh you know
compliments because you would often come
over to me and say you know that that
you know i was supposed to tell chuck to
watch you to see how it's done oh yeah
yeah everybody had to get on my level
james i remember you said to me on set
one day that only eagley
competed with chuck in terms of being a
really great actor
that's only one i think we have not
brought up eagley who of course steals
the show he's peacemaker's pet eagle and
he's peacemaker's best friend and say a
dowel with some green tape on it eagley
stole the show
yeah that's true i also got to say that
i
this is probably the third or fourth
thing i've worked with james on and i've
never seen him more giddy working on
something in my entire life i mean there
was one night we were shooting and the
whole time it was like three in the
morning and james is just running around
laughing like a maniac and he kept
saying i can't believe they're letting
me shoot this yeah
yeah that's the happiest night of my
life i'm like that was warner brothers
funeral that they let me do that we'll
see
i have one i mean this is i believe the
only show
that has john cena dancing for four
minutes in his tighty whities to the
choir boys i don't believe there's ever
been a show that offers that up the
memorable tiny whities
[Laughter]
okay so we're going to be taking some
questions from the fans uh these came
from instagram and twitter so at
remy.c.l asked was there any characters
you wanted to put in peacemaker but
couldn't i guess that's a question to me
the answer is no i did got to put it in
every character i wanted to for john
cena uh at popsignite asks what was the
most difficult part of becoming
peacemaker
i think it was just getting comfortable
being a super
i'm normally just a normal and i
think uh just
just being a high octane was
probably the uh the most difficult part
was that really difficult because it
seemed to come to you pretty easily
okay here's a big question i guess we
can throw this to matt and peter what
can we expect for the show ask at magic
cm 1210 well i mean i think what we can
expect is a truly original superhero
show james wrote all eight episodes he
directed five of the eight and it's just
got that unique tone that james brings
to all the content that he creates so i
think it's something something pretty
special yeah i would also just add to
that that with the action and the
spectacle and the emotion and the comedy
is also like this workplace comedy at
the center of it about all these
characters that kind of come together
it's it's like the office as a superhero
show with more people getting shot in
the face then in the air occasionally
yeah
so at
smrootyanmole asks is peacemaker gonna
go through a journey of changing from a
jerk to a lovable hero in the series or
will he remain that crazy not to be
trusted liberator
that's kind of a spoiler i was going to
say questions that can't be answered
that's that's perfect
it's right up my alley we just can't
give anything away you'll have to you'll
have to watch and see on hbo max what
about the rest of you what did you feel
about you know seeing peacemaker's
journey on this show
i can't really say much so i just
there's definitely um
great character arcs that you will
thoroughly enjoy as an audience you root
for him regardless of his past and you
hope that he will change and i just
thought that was such an interesting
thing to explore with the series i think
one of the interesting things about
adebayon peacemaker is that on paper
they seem very different they seem like
polar opposites but they actually have a
ton of things in common and one of the
things that they're both dealing with
is
loyalty versus morality and
not disappointing people that mean the
most to them and finding the beauty in
each other even though their worlds are
completely different so that was a lot
of fun to play with and and definitely
add it to the layers of our two
characters that's extremely well said
she's the only one he gets along with
she's the only one that thinks he's
funny you know she laughs at him she
throws up blows off the stuff that he
says that's stupid and
realize he's an ignorant and
that to me is really uh special because
it is so much of what the show is about
yeah it uh it was amazing and i'm just
grateful to be a part of this crew
because no one came in with an ego
nobody came in with a chip on their
shoulder but everyone comes in with a
history with something to offer with a
set of skills and it's a bold step
you're
james you're taking a a step into trying
to
grow the genre and we're going to do it
with eight episodes and and hopefully we
have more but everyone has their moment
and that that certainly comes from your
writing really quickly there was a sense
of you know we're gonna have fun doing
this so that really helped and that came
top down the rolls downhill you
know
it's been such a great experience and
such a fun massive experiment uh that
you know i just can't wait to share it
with the the fans uh you know dc fans
and just fans in general yeah i want to
say thank you everybody for giving us
all so much time i really appreciate it
i hope everybody's well and i hope to
see everybody soon good to see you guys
oh man thank you guys so much for all
your questions i'm stoked to see that
you guys are so excited about the series
almost as excited as i am i know i had a
great time i hope you guys did but
before we let you go i have a little
surprise for you it's an exclusive
never-before-seen
first look at a peacemaker teaser
you cool
what does that mean truth is i'm
supposed to be in prison for what
superhero stuff what superhero are you
peacemaker get out of here there's no
superhero called peacemaker dude i'm
famous
[Music]
you're a born killer with expertise in
every weapon under humankind
i'm giving you the chance to stay out of
prison and work for me kill people bad
people
this is hardcore
your handler in the field
you've done economists tech and tactics
and this is our new recruit that they
buy
you don't have to shoot people after her
to kill them
right
who's the guy that's peeking out behind
the trash can vigilantes trying to be
helpful
our first target is senator royland golf
golf may be traveling with his family
are you sure those two kids came out of
those parents that's an attractive
couple and that one looks like it came
out of them but the other one looks good
fun baby a butt baby yeah my older
brother told me there's two types of
babies one that comes out normal and
then butt babies worst in every way they
come out of a woman's butt
well i believed i was a butt baby until
i was like 14. that explains a lot
there's something about him that's
sad
hey dad
i didn't much bro i went to a nancy boy
like you
no lately i'm sticking up a maniac hey
no no that's cause we're born killers
what separates us from other killers is
we only kill bad people
usually
unless there's a mistake
you use being a jerk is a way to push
people away
you suck at powerpoint but if you just
drop that
people actually might like
you wanna taste it
[Music]
wow
oh my god
he's he's hugging me
he's helping me dad grab my phone i
don't want to move
dad still to come supergirl dc league of
super pets and a first look at the flash
movie
[Music]
yes i'm super excited for an up close
and personal look at the superman family
of characters and shows i'm actually a
lifetime fan of the man of steel and now
there's more superman content than ever
before
from the hit series superman and lois
give it up for superman and lois tyler
hecklin and elizabeth tulik
[Music]
thanks grant thank you grant needless to
say we're big fans of you too and we're
so excited to be here thank you to the
fans for giving superman and lois such a
warm welcome into your homes thanks to
you we're coming back for a second
season
but wow season one you had a secret
brother
lois had a lot going on with just about
everyone jordan found out he has powers
jonathan doesn't
and remember how cute you looked when
you were coaching high school football
the sky is the limit for superman and
lois especially in season two here's a
behind the scenes look at our first day
back on set
[Music]
why hello dc phantom welcome to the kent
home well if you'd like to come in just
wipe off your shoes first it's dusty out
there
hey everyone so we're just gonna take
you on a brief tour of the house this is
a staircase that is i want to say it's a
fake staircase but it's not it it just
doesn't go to anything it's like beyond
up there the great beyond that is right
so this is our hallway
um as you can see you got some family
photos and some other stuff and we shoot
i would say the majority of our scenes
are in the kitchen a non-working fridge
with actually look at that nothing in it
tyler has a drawer in this kitchen that
he hides his stuff in
i also have a door in this kitchen that
i hide my stuff in
and i have
a candy stash i have a note saying bitsy
stuff please leave in the drawer more
candy hand sanitizer eye drops water
sides hair things my phone it's like a
freshman locker yeah
let's go into what was formerly martha
kent's bedroom but is now lois's office
personally this is my favorite room in
the house i think it has just the
coolest amount of stuff around there's a
really cute family photo over here if i
had to pick something that i wanted to
take home from set other than my candy
in my candy drawer it would be this
photo one thing i could take home is
this little old camera it's old brown
camera it's really cool i'm always
constantly fidgeting with it and having
to memorize exactly where it was so that
i don't ruin everything
dining room scenes i would say we shoot
most of our eating scenes in the kitchen
we've had some stuff in here out the
window i remember when i first started
shooting on graham i was like oh so cool
there's these crazy
large photographs that get changed
according to time of day the exterior of
the farmhouse is totally separate and we
shoot all the exterior scenes there
anything interior is on our stages
we also shoot a lot in the living room
this was one of my favorite scenes which
was uh the big paint fight yes yeah yeah
that was really fun
so uh sometimes during lunch i come here
and i play piano to unwind a lot of the
crew kind of joins in whatnot and people
start singing along so you know a lot of
people have fun in this uh little room
when we're not exactly working as well
you know
it's fun
my talented son
the boys bedrooms are on another stage
so
because again the upstairs is is to the
great beyond and then there's a porch
that wraps around but we typically shoot
the porch scenes outside on the exterior
farmhouse set
thank you everyone for joining us on
this tour of the kent house we hope you
join us for the rest of season two and
the beyond and uh thanks for watching
[Music]
while we're happy for another season of
our show we're also sad that it's almost
time to say farewell to supergirl the
series is in its sixth and final season
i donned the cape as superman for the
first time on supergirl so it has a
special place in my heart and it is
bittersweet to say farewell to my
on-screen cousin and friend melissa
benoist as supergirl
supergirl reminds us that we are all
powerful and strong the challenge is
realizing our own potential
right now the cast of supergirl
including supergirl herself melissa
benoist have gathered to chat about the
show and share their favorite memories
over the past six seasons let's listen
in
[Music]
hi everybody it's melissa benoist and
i'm here on the set of
[Applause]
supergirl of
my amazing co-stars on the show
we're gonna take a fond look back at the
last six years of the show please join
us
i mean it's changed my life this show um
it's been a a joy and seeing the way
that
this canon and the mythology affects
people and and young girls and the
people that look up to our characters
it's it's very meaningful yeah i would
say that because i wasn't originally
cast as
as the martian manhunter i was actually
just cast as hank
and uh it was it was only after the
pilot that i was made the martian
manhunt i can remember going home with a
pile of
martian manhunter comics and just
reading all of them and thinking this
guy is awesome
so i was just really excited to suddenly
get this brand new character and fall
into this whole
story arc which has really been great
for me and i've i've really i've really
enjoyed not just playing the character
but
you know meeting all these fabulous
people and also learning to directing on
the show as well so it's really been for
me
sort of it's been money it's been
money
my favorite scene is the scene where
staz and melissa do karaoke and sing
africa
i think i think it's it's magical
and i've i i watch it on repeat i love
it so much
they sounded beautiful
it was a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
and you know
both of us come from like a musical
background so it's really nice that at
any point get to kind of
find a way to kind of uh
combine all the mediums of of art so
it's really fun i really liked it my
favorite scene that we ever did is in my
favorite episode and it was slaver's
moon in the quarry things were it was
big rain let's hope this thing works
it was kevin smith's first episode and
he ordered like a bacon bacon truck so
all of us were just eating bacon wrapped
bacon bacon wrapped bacon bread with
like cheese and bacon
pouring rain
rain we were playing games in a random
school bus and then and that was sort of
sort of star wars yeah it was so star
wars it was like a buddy adventure
planet 51 arc b that's maldoria people
that were there the aliens what were
they called slaving is a big business on
maldoria
maldori
of course you remember
in season two i had to eat 10 pancakes
at once yeah thank you
it's not funny my jaw sort of dislocated
a little bit
no that was probably two cents
that is a stunt if you get injured
eating yes
yeah it was it was a big stack of
pancakes and i was like oh this is gonna
be so funny and then my jaw went
like that and also when you ate the
pizza oh you didn't make enough of it it
made like two pizzas and i was like
eating three per taste yeah i had a
pizza scene this season and i was like
maybe i'll eat the whole pizza and
someone was like chris already did that
we do have a fantastic stunt team
give it up for simon outside and and
just the whole team have just been
absolutely really really fantastic the
craziest day i've had stunt wise was on
the green screen and the wires and me in
the harness hanging
and i was with tyler heckman playing
superman and he was like i'm good i'm
good and i was i called it and i was
like i'm done and i walked upset like
this
ladies and gentlemen
it is fun
when you're being carried by supergirl
that one harry potter i've been i've
been carrying questions
it's lovely twice it's quite twice it's
hilarious i'm like come on girl
i think for me that one of the one one
of the funniest things that we did was
cloth magic
has that made it into the world yet
yeah
can i get context i don't even know
cloth magic is cloth magic is a spin-off
show that never quite happened
basically we would just put it put
either of their capes up
and then pull them down and something
would happen behind
them and matt barum who plays mitch on
the show who is hilarious
he's so funny hold on to your jegging
sister
you've got company yeah there's one line
he makes an entrance
and it's just like
basically dot dot oh sorry what's lex
luthor doing here but every single take
he would be like i just tried a
milkshake for the first time
oh sorry what's sorry i got a parking
ticket on this it was just like and i
would like be like looking at lex with
like my eyes watering and then i would
turn around and just break what i think
is the funniest moments or any time
david forgets his line on set that's the
best he's directing
an episode and he's also in the scene
but forgets that he has the first line
of the scene
so
if you know david the way he directs
there's a lot of energy so he'll be like
all right that's it keep that energy
keep that energy all right hand action
line
i get a lot of letters from girls saying
that
they until they saw lena luther on tv
they didn't think it was it okay for
girls to be studying science
and there's a lot of girls who are like
and i'm now in my fourth year in
engineering in engineering and i have
you to thank for that in the show to
thank that and it's such a small thing
it seems like but that's the beginning
of a whole new life for them they didn't
think was possible
because of watching the show there was a
little girl who
is actually a daughter of one of our
crew members who when she met me she
went i felt question is your belt
attached to your skirt or your shirt
no it's winston's daughter
[Applause]
magic
i wore so many belts on this show that
were like top sticked to pants that had
no belt loops
so just taped yes
we had a great moment we did a um
comic-con
uh in chicago
and uh we had the line for people to
come through and get autographs and
whatnot and there was a family this
woman came through with her two
daughters and uh one was oh yeah you
know her biological daughter and then
another the other was adopted yeah and
it was such a wonderful moment because
they looked at the both of us just
saying you embody exactly like what we
have in our house we don't ever get to
see that and to see like a a healthy
family dynamic like that especially you
know and the young girl said like me
being adopted coming to the family
feeling like i was like i belonged
it meant so much that was that i
remember was really really special
i feel like we have to talk about when
you meet
small children who think that you're
really a superhero and think that all of
your powers and everything you do is
real yeah and then getting to navigate
the conversation they're like i just
talked to an um a little girl on set a
little while ago and she was like
make a shield
do it and i was like
i can't and she's like why
i'm
tired
because i'm dreamer it gets sticky for
me because then they'll watch me jump
and then just
fall back to the grounds like i have to
i got to work with
[Music]
very special people and i think i'll
miss you guys the most i think like you
said the collaboration is really great
and
and it's yeah i i think the friendships
is what you miss even if it's hard
sometimes here like there's there's
there's gonna be moments like two months
from now three months from now you go
that's not gonna happen again yeah yeah
and i can just i can tell you straight
up like having been gone a year
you you miss each other yeah it has been
lovely to work with a family a a a real
family type group of people that kind of
support each other that's been i'll
definitely miss
and you know what i do think i'll miss
playing a superhero yeah
when enough time has gone by
and i'm you know i have some energy
to supergirl no no wait wait
to family
love bones us all
just family
[Music]
[Applause]
while it's sad to say goodbye there's
still so much to look forward to in the
dc universe including star girl we've
got a little end of the season teaser
for you so check it out now
[Music]
to the shadows
with you
courtney
[Applause]
record
[Music]
where are we
you think that everything is black and
white
you are my greatest experiment stay away
from earth turn away from the darkness
hi corty
you can't escape
i've hurt
everyone you love
i've tortured your friends
and your family
do you want to play games
dr midnight
[Music]
looks amazing
don't miss that special episode of star
girl there's just so much going on in
the superman universe and just for you
super fans here is a very early look at
the art of my adventures with superman a
brand new animated take on lois clark
and jimmy that's currently in production
[Music]
we are back with some more news from the
world of superman let's check in with dc
publisher and chief creative officer jim
lee to see what's happening with
superman and comics right now
hey everyone i hope you're enjoying dc
fandom as much as i am i'm here to share
news about krypton's favorite son kyle
or as you may know him clark kent aka
superman right now in the pages of
action comics in superman a major event
on war world is building the war world
saga which promises to be the biggest
superman event since the death of
superman after a learning of an enslaved
race with mysterious ties to krypton
superman leaves earth behind and travels
across the galaxy to the throne mongol
and liberate the people on war world
from writer philip kennedy johnson and
artist daniel simpere
action comics 1036 yes 1036
is the first issue in the war world saga
and will be available at your local
comic book shop on tuesday october 26th
this is a story you definitely don't
want to miss and since earth still needs
a superman to protect it while clark is
off fighting for the people on war world
john kent the son of clark and lois lane
has picked up the mantle of superman
here on earth in superman son of cal-el
from writer tom taylor and artist john
timms this is a different younger
superman who's figuring out how he wants
to fight for the future and who he is as
a person you may have recently heard the
news that john kent's relationship with
reporter jay nakamura will be formalized
as john comes out as bisexual in issue
number five out in november and we
couldn't be prouder to tell this
important story we talk a lot about the
power of the multiverse and dc
storytelling and this is an incredible
example
we can have john ken exploring his
identity in the comics as well as john
kent learning about the secrets of his
family on tv in the superman and lowe's
tv show on the cw
i have one more bit of superman news to
share first with you the fans we're
excited to announce that to better
reflect the storylines that we're
telling across dc and to honor
superman's incredible legacy of over 80
years of building a better world
superman's motto is evolving superman
has long been a symbol of hope who
inspires people and is that optimism and
hope that powers him forward with this
new mission statement
truth justice
and a better tomorrow
stay tuned for more dc fandom news
[Music]
still to come the flash blue beetle and
injustice animated dc movies
[Music]
okay guys let's make this a little
interactive raise your hand if you have
a soft spot for superman
same but no matter how deep my
admiration goes for the man of steel i
know someone who's even more of a
superman super fan i'm talking about
superstar nfl great cam newton and get
this cam found a way to incorporate his
love of superman with his passion
for fashion
here's the man himself with a special
announcement
what's going on dc fam hey i'm super
excited to have partnered with the dc
fam as well as my hat company mashika
to create
superman inspired uh mashika hat and
we're dropping it here at dc fandom the
first time i encountered superman had
much of an impact of what
morphed into my career as superman it
was just the aura of knowing that you
could do any and everything you know
outside of you know kryptonite
you know superman doesn't have any flaws
he was just
who he was and i think for me as a
person that's what i would want people
to to know and to feel like you know he
has good energy he has you know great
qualities about him and i think that's
what
that's why i train the way i train
that's why i prepare the way i prepare
that's the way i play the way i play
because it just embodied everything that
i prepared for
fashion is
means to me expressing yourself without
having the ability to speak up for
yourself at times to incorporate that
with superman is something that words
can't even explain because
in essence we all have some type of
super powers
and and we are a superhero
in our own right
it's it's going to be cool to see how we
showed the different sides of superman
in many different ways
i'm super excited to unveil my super
exclusive and that's big super and
that's a big exclusive
uh
superman inspired
meshika hats
take it away
[Music]
thanks cam and i'm it i'm a little
jealous
i mean who wouldn't want a customized
superman hat
honestly i'll be happy with some
superman underoos at this point
remember those
google it
now up next we have a movie that stars
one of the greatest duos of all time
dwayne johnson and kevin hart and of
course they are voicing the animated
characters that will soon top the list
of all time dc faves let's meet crypto
the superdog ace the bat ham and just a
few of the dc league of super pets
[Music]
[Applause]
league of super pet i love it perfect
hey
pets plural
you ever heard of a league with one dude
in it
i have it well they say i'm in a league
of my own oh you're the leaguer you own
all right mm-hmm ain't nobody's messed
up as you
next summer dwayne johnson is crypto
kevin hart as ace
how much did you have to drink
okay how adorable does that movie look i
can't wait to see the trailer when it
arrives and i can totally relate i mean
anyone with a pet knows that their pet
is a super pet am i right
well some of you out there took that
notion one step further by creating a
superhero look for your fur baby it's
canine or cat cosplay and i am so here
for it all right let's see your league
of super pets
so
[Music]
oh
that was so much fun and with halloween
just around the corner hopefully you
guys got some pretty good costume ideas
for you and your furry family members so
stay with us for more ugc including some
pretty cool human cosplay and impressive
fan art also by humans now there's some
true talent out there next up you've got
me geno killiamor smack dab in the
middle of this exciting global event for
dc superfans to tell you that the
excitement continues right now and with
a familiar face or should i say voice
listen up
hey it's matt bulmer i'm one of the
lucky few actors who've had the honor of
voicing the legendary superman you might
remember me from the hit 2013 animated
film superman unbound i'd like to think
that superman represents the qualities
that are the best in all of us
truth
honor
hope
family whether it's the one you're born
into or the one you find someone who's
there to look out for us
and someone who sees all of us as equals
i also had the opportunity to voice the
flash in just a society world war ii
which premiered earlier this year and
because the dc multiverse is vast and
constantly expanding i'm lucky enough to
play the awesome and complex hero
negative man on dc's doom patrol here's
a sneak peek at what's coming up for the
rest of this season
there are mysterious things in this
world that they're keeping an eye on and
in my death i must now place that burden
upon your shoulders
arrival imminent
come on gay
how am i supposed to fix this alone my
tech is part of who i am it's got
nothing to do with who you are i think
there's something he needs to show me
i want to be a better person what am i
doing
she must be eliminated
we appear to be dead something very ugly
is set to occur and it needs to be
stopped
who is the sisterhood of doubter
insidious cutthroat terrorists
how does this crap keep happening to us
we're all the way through the looking
glass now
there's no turning back
there's something weird going on with
you something going on with you why am i
here
they are coming for us
when one expels a parasite there is
really only one reasonable response
give it a name oh jesus christ
hello
i'm april my name is michelle gomez it's
your boy javan wade i'm dang
i am thrilled to be a part of the dc
universe things are going to get very
exciting with the new fourth season of
team patrol did i see four full seasons
yes i said four
celebrate with us by watching the first
three seasons
no
things are about to heat up
boo
[Music]
if you haven't seen doom patrol yet
hopefully that teaser intrigued you i
mean it's such a cool and quirky and
totally unpredictable series i
absolutely love it and i'm super excited
to see how this season wraps up now
speaking of wrapping up we've got the
season of gift giving just around the
corner now have you started your
shopping yet god knows i haven't or
maybe you know you want to get something
for yourself a new t-shirt or a hat or
both you know just complete the look
don't forget to check out shop.dc comics
for all kinds of merchandise and
collectibles in fact i do believe we're
having a flash sale right now
check it out
[Music]
greetings dc fandom and domers ezra
miller here live from the set of the
flash it looks like this
we're very excited to show you the movie
and we can't yet because we're still
making it we wanted to show you a teaser
but we can't because
we don't have enough material to make a
teaser yet
we can't make a trailer
but we do have this small sneak peek
that my maestro andy and i have put
together that we really hope you enjoy
and i will see you in theaters later
next year or more importantly you will
see me
[Music]
tell me something
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
any universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
let's fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
oh
abc fandom this is john ridley and i'm
here to talk about the other history of
the dc universe
what is the other history of the dc
universe for me honestly it's a couple
of things
part of it as the title indicates it
really is about otherization
it's about people who have been
traditionally on the margins in real
life and storytelling but have been
there have been there through
history the history of the dc universe
have
um
in many ways been part of the fabric of
the dc universe but their stories
haven't always fully been told and not
necessarily also been told by
individuals who have a lived experience
that mirrors those individuals you know
when i was growing up like a lot of
folks who read part of being a fan is
really filling in the spaces between the
pages or between the issues
and
what would have diana what would bruce
what if clark what would they have done
you know in in in the quiet spaces what
would they have done between fighting
crime what would they have done between
saving the universe and there's just
this natural thing i think for fans to
want to continue that thought to want to
continue that storytelling and i think
certainly for an individual like myself
when it was
when i was growing up at least it was
still pretty rare to see people of color
um at the center of stories
to see them fully rendered to see things
again that felt like they had a lived
experience so a lot of the other history
of the dc universe
is really
my history of the dc universe and things
that i thought and things that i felt
and things that sometimes i literally
imagined about stories
but became part of the universe that i
knew and that i carried with me for
years
to me they're some of the most
interesting characters all of those
characters black lightning
mal and karen who were the guardian or
herald and bumblebee tatsu yamashiro
who is katana renee the question and
anissa pierce who is jefferson's
daughter it was
important for a couple of reasons i i
think that they are
amazing defining dc characters
um when you look back on the history of
dc almost every one of those characters
has really transformed the landscape
transformed the narrative and have been
iconic mal and karen
their journey is just two young people a
young couple of color who in love and
committed i mean when that came out in
the
late 1970s early 1980s
even without trying
the message that was sent with those two
characters young committed couple of
color was was powerful renee her journey
from being a beat cop back in batman the
animated series to now being the
commissioner in gotham city
is an extraordinary journey um
jefferson pierce the first black
character in the dc universe to
have his own series that he fronted
characters that i really cared about
stories that i remember characters that
had to me great lineage
those were characters that i wanted to
take a deep dive into
and now for some news on the sandman we
are thrilled to reveal the first look of
the incredible gwendolyn christie as
lucifer based on the comic book series
created for dc by neil gaiman the
sandman follows the people and places
affected by morpheus the dream king as
he mends the cosmic and human mistakes
he's made during his vast existence look
out for the series coming soon to
netflix
coming up a surprise cast reunion gotham
knights and fat woman
[Music]
i'd like to take a moment to personally
thank warner brothers home entertainment
for bringing injustice to the small
screen now as you probably know since
you're a super fan like i am injustice
the film was inspired by the injustice
video game and subsequent comic series
written by tom taylor that means you can
expect all the hardcore action-packed
excitement in this animated film version
but
i gotta say and i gotta apologize in
advance to all the kids out there this
one is for adults only i know i know
where's the justice in that but then
again that's why they called it
injustice right so here's more
i'm pulling
the best joke ever
it'll be my
masterpiece
11 million dead
injustice
dc's most powerful heroes and villains
learn that the weight of the world can
either inspire one to rise victorious
or be crushed asunder you'll throw away
everything the justice league stands for
everything you stand for
superman can make a perfect world oh so
now he's god
this tragedy of gods and humans locked
in battle over ideological and
philosophical differences transcends
artistic media as the amazing franchise
of injustice
has gone from video game to comic book
series to a new pulse-pounding animated
film
all hostilities will stop
or i will stop them the laws of superman
will not be the laws of atlantis
if we continue on this path
we go from policing to occupying to
jailing then becoming tyrants
or justice is finally done
injustice gods among us
and injustice 2
allowed for players to choose their
champion and test their middle
against dc's greatest pantheon of heroes
and villains i know you won't step aside
but you are not going to stop us
you saw how prepared father was he has
plans for all of us you need allies
this visceral and exciting fighting game
was the impetus for the injustice saga
to continue in a jaw-dropping comic book
series
expanding the electrifying and at times
terrifying battle between superman's
regime and batman's insurgency
any hero that doesn't pledge loyalty to
the justice league will be considered a
fugitive
now this universe can be experienced as
a full-length animated feature film as
injustice
will bring to life the thrills intrigue
and drama
fans should expect from this hallmark
adventure
how many people
husbands wives and children will you
kill for peace
can we forgive earth's greatest adopted
son for his crimes against humanity
this is injustice
a world where tragedy loss
and the fight for the greater good will
change everything
all right we're gonna take a deep dive
into the world of injustice joining me
is netherrealm studios ed boon
co-creator of the best-selling injustice
gods among us and injustice 2 video
games and creative consultant on the
injustice animated movie and you'll
recognize him from this is us and
smallville the voice of superman in
injustice justin hartley guys uh let's
jump right in this is
so exciting that injustice has now
become an animated film i got to ask you
ed when we were creating this franchise
i mean you know the comic book the
animated film it's all it started with a
video game which is so so cool but was
that ever the original design
no as a matter of fact it's always been
backwards the video game industry has
done so many games based on movies or
comic books or tv shows and it's so cool
to see it just done the opposite way
where the video game starts it and it
just spawns off comics animated things i
you know this is one of the funnest
parts about making the game is seeing it
kind of grow into something even bigger
justin when you first heard about coming
and being superman in this what was your
reaction superman is the character that
um you know when you grow up as a little
boy that's who you everybody wants to be
superman and then when you get older
especially when you become an actor and
you start to dissect these characters
that you play you go my god that's
almost an impossible
character to play you know who how do
you do something like that
someone who has no flaws yeah um
and what's interesting about that
which was
what drew me to this character because
we find him in a place where he is
flawed that's what i love about
injustice that is that you put your own
spin on dc and these legendary
characters i got to ask when you were
first kind of conceiving of this
property i mean what was the genesis of
the idea you know our studio our studio
is netherrealm where the you know the
mortal kombat team right we would use
the term evil superman but it's a lot
deeper than that the story is
what would happen if superman was the
most powerful being in the universe was
taken to the breaking point and that's
it sounds like that's part of what
really appealed to you about this role
right yeah yeah of course because it's
like you said you know we all have our
back you snap in traffic you get home
you shoot your mouse up you say
something that you don't mean what if
you were superman and you did that yeah
and then it's like oh god this title
wave is i mean this is just a
never-ending yeah this could be no
backing out of it too he's just so
committed into it and one thing i wanted
to ask you about was the collaboration
with rick morales on this and you're a
creative consultant for this and i'm
sure you know you strike a balance
between knowing that this is an animated
film you know you're coming from the
video game world but what was that
collaboration like and how much do you
want to give the you know the team
creative liberties to build things
versus you know being very authentic to
the game story it's mainly focused on
the comic books but the catalyst of what
happened that kind of really triggered
superman is featured in both the comics
and the games people who know and love
injustice will see new stuff they would
i was blown away at all the
all the characters that they have in
this thing there's just so many
it's a great like dc
fan service really you know and was so
cool because we have these super moves
in the game
and you see a couple of them in there i
just jumped out of my seat when i saw
the i don't want to give away again
which one it was but they they have some
of those kind of classic iconic moments
from the games in there again they
follow the story of the comics mainly
but the the moments that they have from
the games you tell you can tell that
they specifically set out let's recreate
that scene let's recreate those
superman what was your twist on it
honestly the story was so rich the story
in the film is so rich and it's it's
pretty obvious what's happening as it's
happening yeah he's in a bad way
um
yeah so there's really no getting around
that you just kind of have to lean into
that yeah the arguments between superman
and batman to me that dynamic yeah you
know each having a point superman's
probably a little bit over the top but
uh
but each having a point is is such a
great back and forth exactly yes exactly
now you're going to have to get a role
in mortal kombat that's it right
this is the audition for mk or something
well uh thank you so much for joining us
guys uh the movie is incredible you know
i'm a huge fan of ed and all you've done
with the games and i love that this is
such an authentic uh interpretation of
the the franchise and justin you do a
great job uh you know focusing on on
superman's uh story so
um
can't wait to watch it it's coming out
very soon but right now here's anson
mout uh the film's voice of batman with
a first look at an all-new clip from
injustice
thanks jeff
the vast majority of superheroes and
super villains are born of a singular
event in their lives that dramatically
alters their physical or mental state or
both
a flash of lightning
an animal or insect bite
an untimely exposure to some form of
radiation or substance
or the death of a loved one as the
ultimate invincible boy scout superman
has always avoided such trappings until
the moment in this film clip which
serves as the catalyst for the central
plot in our film
injustice
let's take a look
the joker is no longer in metropolis
he's stolen a submarine with harley
quinn they took lois with them
i see it batman one of the warheads is
missing
[Music]
where is she
doomsday
no
i will not let you hurt anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
time to go harley good guys are coming
and they tend to get punchy
you're not going anywhere
[Music]
scarecrows fear toxin mixed with
kryptonite particles
what did you do i'm pulling
the best joke ever
it'll be my
masterpiece
superman stop whatever you're seeing
it's not real
[Music]
yourself
injustice looks absolutely intense
needless to say i have my popcorn ready
and i am warming up my favorite recliner
now to another character one who may be
blue in color but he'll surely brighten
up your screen let's learn more about
the blue beetle in our dc spotlight
hey this is fandom my name is angeli
manuel soto the director of libido and
i'm super excited to be here and with me
i got a couple friends hi i'm gareth
donatal jose i am the screenwriter of
blue beetle hey everyone show mariduena
i am jaime reyes you might know him as
blue beetle i'm excited to be here for
this panel and we'll just hop right into
it i am humbled and excited to be able
to
bring blue beetle to life it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be funny it's gonna be
crazy
but it also has feelings it's it's all
of those things like latin american
people are all of those things
and the movie reflects that this
contains uh uh all of what's great about
blue beetle in my opinion in a way
that's very exciting and that's only
gonna
get better and better as these guys take
it away
the scarab is one of the most powerful
piece of technology in the universe that
has made its way across eons and neons
and neons and landed in front of
heimerdies
the thing that i that i've loved the
most about comic book series is that you
see different versions of suits like you
see
uh like the metal version and you see
the flying suit version and this this
and that and i'm just so excited with
each you know superhero movie it just
you have to one-up each other so i know
for a fact
that any of the other superheroes out
there who think they have the best
superhero suit i'm calling you out for a
rap battle
we got the best suit over here at blue
beetle and i haven't even seen it that's
how confident
what i love about blue beetle it's a
deeply american character right
what i really like about jaime is that
he gets to be a reflection of somebody
who's been around us forever right a
mexican-american kid who wants to be a
part of this world who wants to to have
a piece of this world who wants to be
able to thrive in this world and like a
lot of people like him finds himself
hitting the same obstacles that a lot of
us face seeing the evolution of the
blueberry character
this film kind of like opens the door
for a new
like the new generation of what blue
beetle can become at the hands of jaime
and like you said it is everything
that makes us who we are one of the
things that gareth did beautifully was
capture the latino family in its core as
how we see them not as how somebody
tells us or how somebody has seen it
from a third person perspective and for
once we're able to see a hero that comes
from a family from a similar economic
background to the ones that we came up
and stands for and that represents
the majority of the people who are the
ones that are coming from the bottom
that closeness of family
is something that makes jaime different
than other characters that i had seen
before and that potential to me was
beautiful peter parker gets bit by a
spider
and one of his first instincts is to
hide it from his family well you're from
a mexican family good luck hiding
anything from anybody i'm so excited to
be able to
not only be a latino on screen but have
the opportunity to show kids like
you can you can do it too i'm ready
we're gonna shake things up we're gonna
bring you guys a story that you guys
haven't seen before and and then do it
with with uh with a smile on your face
so we're ready i'm very happy to work
with this guy
i love this guy
so everybody welcome to the family
that's all the facts and thank you for
welcoming us to the family this is gonna
be great thank you so much
smallville premiered exactly 20 years
ago today which is just crazy to mark
the occasion let's take a look at some
of the show's most memorable moments
previously on smallville
what's happening
what are you doing clark
lana so what are you man or superman i
haven't figured it out yet
your real parents weren't exactly from
around here what do you mean
you are the last son of krypton
who are you lois lois lane
what kind of a monster are you you were
right about me all along mr champ i am
the villain of the story
are you okay i've waited for this for so
long i just don't want it to go away i'm
not going anywhere we have been down a
long road together
one paved with difficult trials
those trials
are behind you now trust me small bill
we can make this work
oh boy can we
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on you didn't think that was it did
you please welcome clark kent tom
welling how are you great thank you for
having me and we've got lex luthor
michael rosenbaum joining us as well
real treat trying to figure out how to
sit on this couch to look real
comfortable or when you guys started the
show did you ever think that 20 years
after the premiere you would be here at
a dc event talking about the show
michael
uh
you know what
i before i did smallville i wasn't
really on any successful series they
were just sort of one season two season
and then i saw the pilot of this i
called my mom and i said
i think i'm finally gonna get noticed in
my life for a lot of you guys on the
show this was like the first big moment
did you have kind of those same feelings
when you watched it or when you were
yeah i mean i i lacked a great deal of
uh experience
uh at the time well no i did i mean and
at no point do they say
you're going to be here for 10 years we
just never knew we were always just sort
of grinding and trying to elevate
everything we could do and it was a team
effort we helped each other out a lot i
remember just being on set with tom and
either it'd be him telling me or me
telling him he'd go
do it again yeah ask for another it
became a trust thing for us
because we were together so much and
there were also times where like you
know he his character talked a lot mine
didn't not like real life at all no at
all and i remember specifically there
was a scene in the luther mansion where
you know clark just appears there lex
turns and he sees clark and he starts to
talk and he walks over he pours himself
a glass he comes back and he's talking
to me and literally i think my line back
to you was
and
and you go
that's uh that's all you have to say
like that's your only line and i'm like
i would be like i would say these whole
things these soliloquies pages of
dialogue and then all of a sudden and
then he'd go
so
and i go that's all he has
he's got so was there a moment on set
for you guys where you were watching him
perform and you're like holy crap he's
lex luthor or yeah that's superman i
mean you just embodied clark i mean you
just it was fitting that you hadn't done
a ton of stuff
it just was the perfect timing the
perfect storm
he just had that vulnerability that nate
vulnerability and that kindness and
charm lex obviously was ahead of the
game but saw the potential in clark and
saw that clark didn't know what he was
doing yeah you know what i mean like
that all that all sort of worked out and
and one thing to remember it was never
about being superman it was about not
knowing what your future is yeah and a
big thing for lex was
you know making your future what you
want it to be yeah you know so it was a
it was a good dynamic but her question
really was were you in awe of me when
you watched my performance
no not that i recall over the years
there have been so many special guests
on smallville here are some who wanted
to say hello
happy 20th anniversary smallmouth happy
20th anniversary smallville happy 20th
anniversary smallville hot dog i can't
believe it's been 20 years one of my
favorite memories working on smallville
was being directed by tom welding
whenever someone asked me who was my
favorite director i've ever worked with
i just saved
superman
obviously they let me do so many of the
stunts like running the side on the
train and things like that i got to do
everything playing live
and i had a ball doing it smallville
resonated with people because it was the
perfect balance of
heart and drama and extremely high
stakes
stuff that we associate with superhero
stories now
i mean you see people who have been
touched by the show and
it it helps me appreciate it and seeing
of course our boy glover up there lionel
luther i wish he was right here i know i
love i love we love being here
if you could change anything about the
show is there a moment that you would go
back and be like i mean i always thought
that we should have seen a bruce wayne
like can you imagine clark
barging in to your mansion and like
you're talking to somebody and you're
like i'd like you to meet mr wayne and
he'd just be like this cool thing nobody
knows who anybody is
awesome that would have been great by
the way you know it's kind of cool to
think that you know the rest of these
series like arrow and flash and all
these things it was kind of like it
started with smallville well i think you
and i have discussed this that it was um
again a perfect storm in that technology
had literally just gotten to the point
where the visual effects the super speed
and those visual they just didn't do
that before smallville and that's uh
you know they couldn't it did set a
version of a standard smallville is
still kind of contemporary still kind of
looks cool i mean we're in kansas
there's pine trees everywhere but
i didn't even notice that now for sure
by the way what the hell was with lex
luthor's security he would walk in
he would just show up and i go
clark and my reaction really wanted to
be
did you knock that's true hey where's my
security here serious question with the
finale what was that like for you guys
getting to be like okay we're gonna some
people that we haven't seen for a little
bit are gonna get to come back we're all
gonna reconnect here on the show a lot
of people think i quit the show and i
didn't quit my contract was for six
years and i ended up doing seven years
when the finale came the series finale i
called the writers a week before like a
week and a half before and said i wanted
to be with everybody at the end yeah and
so i showed up after not having seen tom
for like three years and it was a bit
emotional very emotional for him yes and
the first take remember the first take
big crank
clark comes in and the mansion's
destroyed and there's this big crane
shot big swooping
crane shot and it comes in and goes past
clark lex comes in
here's michael cameron comes in
reclusive he goes a lot what's my life
what's the line it's a line again
i was like welcome back welcome back
we are almost out of time but before we
go let's hear some messages from some
more familiar faces it's not every day
that a series can celebrate like this
and i'm honored to have been part of
this iconic story happy 20 years
smallville happy 20th anniversary
smallville 20 20th
no it was my first real big job it also
was welcoming me into
an entire universe a world that was so
rich and so loved already it was really
a privilege i remember arriving on set
and seeing tom and it struck me
immediately and i'm like my god it's
clark kent we tackled some pretty
serious subject matter and then you
would sort of when they called cut
everyone's laughing and joking and
oliver and lex are laughing on the floor
you know cracking each other up it was a
really really great set i am so thrilled
that i got to be a part of such an
iconic series and i just wanted to
celebrate with you guys so happy 20th
smallville cast and crew thank you for
having me be a part of your journey and
i'm sending everyone so much love
awesome cassidy freeman
i remember she
called me she's probably got to be a
little nervous going on to the show
that's been
on for years and i just talked about how
great everybody was and how comfortable
she'll be such a mild-mannered person
but when the camera rolled she was a
force yeah there was a scene where she
had to like turn on that luther blood in
a sense and i was like oh this girl is
gonna be all right like she's gotta it
was fun it was fun killing her in season
two it's great
and now someone that i know we're
missing is lana lang kristen crook she
wanted to be here with us but she
couldn't today so she sent a very
special message
happy 20th anniversary smallville we
haven't worked on this show for 12 years
now
and you both and everyone were a huge
part of my
early adult years
when it came out you know it was right
after 9 11
it was a time when
people were looking for
heroes on another level it was a story
and is a story and i think this is why
it lasts it's a story about growing up
it's a story about how you feel
alienated how you feel other and that is
a universal experience for us and clark
kent was that seeing him grapple with
these things that would become his
strengths
give all of us the aspirational hope
that those things that are weird and we
can't control and seem like they make us
different from everyone else are
actually the things that are special
about us and i think that will resonate
always congratulations on the 20th
anniversary of smallville that brings us
to the end of our celebration i want to
thank you all for being here watching us
and taking this trip with us down memory
lane and thank you guys so much for
being here and chatting thank you see
you soon
[Music]
the greatest thing about a news flash is
that it can happen when you least expect
it
like now continuing from may's festival
of heroes anthology comic dc's monkey
prince will return in february 2022 and
a new 12-issue comic book series from
writer jean lun yang and artist bernard
chang based on the 16th century chinese
novel journey to the west dc's newest
shape-shifting superhero the monkey
prince aka marcus sun will return to
headline his own series for fans that
can't wait for february 2022 to read
more about dc's monkey prince a new
short story just posted to
dcuniverse.com
in this new tale available now you'll
see the classic journey to the west
characters defending the heavenly realm
against darkseid and his parademons
[Music]
how's everyone doing out there i am so
glad to be back with you all at dc
fandom what an amazing celebration of
everything dc look last year i had just
been cast so i have a very special
connection with dc fandom it was their
first year it was my first year so let's
do this okay now you know you can't have
dc without gc gotham city it's dark
gritty it's riddled with crime and
corruption but that's why we all love it
am i right gotham is home to some really
amazing characters beyond batman i for
one can't wait to slip into my costume
for another season of batwoman all the
gotham content you can handle is coming
your way right now
first up an action rpg based on some of
the most beloved members of the bat
family maybe you've heard of gotham
knights let's play
[Music]
batman
jim gordon
they thought they had a handle on this
city
they never did
you
don't stand a chance
because they're always watching
always listening
pulling everybody's strings
mine
yours
but no one talks about them
[Applause]
not a whispered word is said the court
of owls is a myth
they're listening
[Music]
if you really want to go down this
rabbit hole you need to know there's no
coming back from it
[Music]
one of the joys of writing comics is the
hope that someone will take that story
and make it something their own
and i think the folks at werner brothers
have done a tremendous job translating
and evolving the quarter vowels into the
game the fans they cosplays these
characters they're hungry for more and
so here you are getting to play out that
that conflict in a game itself
i remember taking this walk around new
york city to my old neighborhood nothing
i knew was there anymore all of the
people i had known had moved away um all
of the stores were gone the feeling was
so unsettling and i wanted to craft a
story that would make bruce wayne feel
the way i felt the first time i read
that story i was just blown away because
they were creating this really rich
secret history of gotham city very
plausible believable that was in direct
opposition to batman i think probably
inspiration uh for the court of owls
originates from nature just by the real
fact that the owl is a natural predator
to the bat what an owl does a lot of the
time is it hunts you and it stalks you
without you seeing it and the fun of the
way that the court goes after bruce is
to watch him from afar for years because
it's been something that's been in
gotham for so long and been so powerful
and right beneath batman's nose i think
that's the root of the success there
one of the biggest challenges with
bringing the court of owls from comic
books to video games is really the
interactive nature of what video games
are how do you take that history how do
you take this cool imagery and bring it
to life in a game that's very satisfying
we could look at the source material we
could talk to the creators and we could
ask their opinions about that we could
say which of these elements do you think
we can translate when i went out there
to see what they were doing with the
game i was blown away i mean it took
what we had done with court of owls but
it just elevated it beyond a lot of the
borders that we had had you can't really
rely on what you think you know about
the court we have expanded we have added
to it
there are different varieties of talons
in gotham nights
and as the players begin to understand
through gameplay the unique strengths
and vulnerability of the talent it will
affect how they equip themselves and how
they unlock new abilities so like any
good rpg we're presenting you with a
problem and then we're presenting you
with a range of potential solutions and
players will have an opportunity to kind
of maximize that according to their own
style
the entire team has worked so hard on
this and put so much love and dedication
into this and i really hope it comes
through and it gives them a really
enjoyable experience i can't wait for us
to share more information about this
game but watch out for those deadly
talents because they are sharp
be careful
[Music]
the court of owls looks truly sinister i
can't wait to know more about those
mysterious mass supervillains in their
deadly creatures forget girls night out
i'll be doing gotham nights in as soon
as i get my hands on that game so
excited
i gotta tell you being in the hall of
heroes is a huge honor look at this
place this is incredible i hope you guys
are enjoying the show so far dc is
throwing a lot of really amazing content
our way and they're not stopping anytime
soon more news flashes more
announcements and more exclusive footage
is on the way but first a heartfelt
thank you for supporting batwoman i've
read your letters i've seen your fan art
and i spend probably too much time on
social media looking at your comments
and feeling the love you have for this
character about my character oh hey girl
hey
don't i got any love you know behind
every superhero is a super villain well
you know alice is a fan favorite
look everybody please say hello to
rachel scarson who plays alice on the
show hello dc world i am so excited to
return to my evil ways on the show and
most of all to get to work with the
lovely javisa again season two set up
many new mysteries characters a new hero
which we'll take a special look at in
just a few minutes and we're going to
get into all of it this season by the
way i will not be the only villain on
the show this season did you see the
premiere mad hatter poison ivy and a
whole slew of baddies joining in the fun
makes sense it would take some of
gotham's most notorious villains and a
little push from renee montoya to get
batwoman and alice to team up and work
together this season
by the order of the mayor's office in
exchange for your cooperation in these
cases you will be remanded in the
supervised custody you're tying my fate
to a psychopath
well more like handcuffing it but yes
any questions
yes does this kind of wreck my ensemble
[Music]
i mean i get the whole bat motif but
this is a um 44-story building shortly
there's a more comfortable workspace
available good luck with that i'm just
gonna
hang out here
what the hell are you two doing together
anyway aren't y'all supposed to be
enemies
long story
she's working with me you're a little
short staffed at city hall
if crazy stuff's going down may as well
get the crazy ladies take on it
we don't
really use the c word anymore
crazy
alice and batwoman are working together
no i have to see it to believe it well
rachel should we give them a taste of
what's to come on season three of
batwoman perhaps a little bit of that
never before seen stuff would uh wet
their appetite i hope so here's a look
as the
resident expert on predatory behavior i
had some thoughts on how mr uh
juices his prey
i was thinking back to
my first kill for which i chose a
geriatric harpy with an oxygen tank now
do you know why i did that because
you're a killer alice no
well yes but
that's not the takeaway i chose her
because she was easy pickings see when a
fledgling predator is learning how to
stalk its prey it seeks to um
separate one from the herd
so he wouldn't have gone after two
victims for his first hunt
look at you learning to think like a
killer
which means
the pool wasn't this crocs first attack
and if it wasn't for all the blood in
the deep end they would have just been
listed as missing persons just like
missing persons i found that were last
seen
at the east river shore a mere two miles
from the pool attack
welcome to his hunting grounds
well i guess i stand corrected maybe
alice and batwoman can work together
quite the twisted partnership rach i
have had so much fun filming with you
for season three i know me too
and i cannot wait for everyone to see
how our story unfolds well i should get
back to practicing my maniacal laugh
never know when i'm gonna need it
bye bye rach if you like nail biting
what's gonna happen next plot twisty
television then i'll see you for season
three of fat woman and one of the newest
heroes of the cast gets his own dc
spotlight right now
[Music]
well hey thanks javisia what's up guys
it is very good to finally be back with
y'all virtually for this year's dc
fandom it's cameras johnson here i play
luke fox on batwoman so at the end of
season two i finally became bad wing
dc's flying armor superhero and playing
batwing has been a ton of fun so far i
mean
tell me you saw that dope scene in the
season three premiere when me and javisa
teamed up and took down the mad hatter
if you haven't yet
it's my bad but if you did i mean like
that's pretty dope right come on so
let's take a look at the origins of this
character and how we brought him to life
on tv for the very first time
batwing made his first appearance in
2011 in the dc comic book series batman
and corporate so before luke fox david
zavimbe known as the batman of africa
was introduced in the fifth issue by the
time david retired luke had proven his
value to batman
just fyi no sidekick actually likes
being referred to as a sidekick copy
that my number two dude nope not that
luke may not have superpowers but he was
a skilled fighter having trained in
mixed martial arts and cage fighting so
as the son of lucius fox luke had the
same brilliant engineering mind as his
father his tech savvy battling suit
allowed him to accomplish some very
impressive stunts like flying tremendous
speeds with a special mechanical glider
cape now there are a few differences
between the batwing of the comics and
the one i portray on television
how are you
justice
[Music]
luke and tavara were friends in the
comics before becoming rivals whereas on
batwoman tap her off as a full-blown
villain from the start
comic book luke builds the suit with his
dad but on our show it's lucious who
actually creates the batwing suit based
off of luke's childhood drawings in the
season 2 finale luke discovers this
years after his dad dies
when i was a kid
i drew pictures of how i imagined a
black batman would look turns out that
my dad was secretly turning those
pictures into reality
[Music]
i can't even describe the feeling of
putting on the suit for the first time
the costume designer maya manning and
her incredible team did an amazing job
designing it and helping me betray this
character the way that i envisioned him
on the big screen
it truly is an honor knowing that i'm
giving kids like me the opportunity to
look up and relate to another black
superhero i mean it's such a surreal
experience and i
can't stop smiling about it when i think
about it because you know i'm just
a random kid from a random town in a
random state that had big dreams and
wanted to make a difference
i looked up to so many superheroes
growing up and i hope that some kid out
there can see me
as batwing and realize that there's a
hero in them too
and one day we might just need to meet
them now as some of you may know and the
true homies have copies sitting on their
shelves right now um i also wrote a
batwing story for dc's batman urban
legends anthology series i was given
this fun opportunity to choose any
villain i wanted for batwing to take on
except the joker and i won't forget that
so
i chose to not only go for my second
favorite rogues gallery villain the
riddler i also decided to give him some
killer croc backup so my friends and i
at dc had a uh we had such a fun time
playing with both baddies and one
action-packed story two incredibly
fulfilling moments at once right writing
my first dc story about batwing and
announcing to the world that i'd be
batwing on the same day
happy batwing day my my journey to
becoming batwing has been one that i'll
never forget you know one that i i hope
some of you out there can find
inspiration from and one that i would
love to continue on together for some
time to see just how much fun
being the metal bat really can be it's
all my love to you all thanks again for
crowning me your newest hero and i can't
wait to show you even more batwing this
season
on baton
[Music]
welcome back dc fans we are excited to
share that the winner of the round robin
fan bracket robbins is available now on
dc universe infinite over one million
fans voted in the massive winner take
all bracket green lighting robins from
writer tim seeley and baldemar rivas as
all the robins come together to talk
about how being a robin has affected
their lives they are violently
interrupted by someone who claims she
was the first robin the last time fans
voted on the fate of a robin it went
very differently dc universe subscribers
can read this digital first title now
only on dcui
still to come catwoman hunted dc's
legends of tomorrow and the new batman
trailer debut hello again to all our
fellow super fans from all around the
globe once again i'm eric borgo and i am
alina ginis so far today's journey
through the dc multiverse has been
amazing we saw dwayne johnson as black
adam and jason momoa returning as
aquaman the dc multiverse means we also
doubled down the flash took a trip to
metropolis and gotten city and got the
exclusive intel on the latest video
games but there's also jason moore you
already mentioned him no but once is
never enough oh god
uh well anyway guys there's still so
much ahead including the batman i cannot
wait for that but right now it's all
about gotham's truly finnish feline
catwoman catwoman is clawing her way
into a new animated film for more on
this exciting project please welcome the
actress who voices the title role
elizabeth gillies
[Music]
catwoman celebrates her 80th anniversary
next year and warner brothers animation
dc and warner brothers home
entertainment salute her longevity and
popularity with the release of a dc
animated movie all her own catwoman
hunted the felonious feline is voiced by
moi and as you'll see in the trailer
catwoman sets her sights on stealing the
world's most valuable jewel and as a
result everyone is hot on her tail get
ready for the world premiere of the
catwoman hunted trailer
i assume you're ready for action this
kitten's always ready for action
darling you're even more gorgeous in
person
multiple countries have warrants out for
your arrest i'm popular this little
kitten sauntered into the lair of the
wrong big cat
i thought this was supposed to be a
party
my kind of party
minerva is built to leviathan crime
syndicate it's now richer than many
countries you help us bust leviathan
your warrants disappear
catwoman
must die
i did not sign up for this did you sign
up for this um
you really have to think about that
prepare to get your ass kicked
don't make me fight dirty
[Music]
a cat always yeah yeah lands on her feet
i've heard the saying don't you ever get
tired of that catch stick
darling i love your costume hold on to
that one love or i might just steal him
away
[Music]
wasn't that just perfect
catwoman hunted will be the first dc
animated movie to be released by warner
brothers home entertainment in 2022
coming to digital blu-ray and 4k on
february 8th all totaled fans can expect
five original dc animated movies in 2022
as well as the spring release of the
latest dc showcase collection anchored
by the all new animated short
constantine house of mystery featuring
matt ryan reprising his role as the
hellblazer ever wonder what would happen
if two youthful super teams joined
forces to fight the bad guys you'll find
out in spring 2022 in teen titans go and
dc superhero girls mayhem in the
multiverse
brightest days and blackest nights
arrive next summer when green lantern
beware my power adds to the dc universe
movies canon and in the fall the next
generation of superheroes takes center
stage in battle of the super suns the
first dc universe movie to be produced
in cg
rounding out the year the world's
greatest detective will look to unmask
the holiday killer when batman the long
halloween deluxe edition comes to
stunning 4k ultra hd
alini we're so spoiled with all of these
amazing dc projects coming our way now
let's talk about the dc show that's
about to hit the 100 episode mark that's
right dc's legends of tomorrow is going
to achieve that impressive milestone in
season 7 and right now we're gonna
celebrate by looking at 100 episodes in
100 seconds are you ready go
nice evil decided to come
we can be on our way
shall we
in the future my friends may not be
heroes
but if we succeed they will be
remembered as legends
[Music]
i made you a certain promise
jax we gotta go
i don't want to enjoy this for a moment
well
let's party
the three of us are going to change our
past and our future and the world as you
know it
and that's just the beginning
i just need one more moment far too slow
we're never gonna make it
don't worry the rest of the legends are
here we're busting everybody out
there's land ahead all hands on deck
[Music]
let's do this
i can't do that
wait
as i was saying legends
this mission has to be epic and i have
the perfect plan
what's that
can we kill them now
verbal
[Applause]
oh my
take us to defcon 2. is this a drill
are they lowering the barrier
wow that i did not see coming
hey jeez
you wish what is it that is just
business as usual for
take us
that there might not be a normal
but i might be okay
[Music]
i told you guys we can't keep the cowboy
narrator
sorry
sorry hey man we'll drop you off
happy trails legends
it's true that every generation has
their favorite batmobile my personally
is the dark knight trilogy batmobile
from the tdk trilogy but for the next
generation of dc fans warner brothers
animation has been revving up production
on their preschool series about some of
the coolest dc vehicles of course led by
the one and only batmobile but that's
not all your favorite heroes iconic
villains and all the citizens of gotham
city are taking on vehicle form and dc's
bat wheels and you don't have to be a
preschooler to love this show you just
have to be a kid at heart this is really
fun for the whole family so let's check
out this very early preview
[Music]
but even heroes
is big news coming from the world of
audio our friends at spotify have
completed casting for the upcoming audio
series batman unburied but you don't
want to hear the news from us we'll let
barbara gordon tell you what up everyone
at dc fandom it is gina rodriguez and i
am so excited to let everyone know that
i am going to be a part of batman i'm
buried
and i get the honor of playing the
iconic voice of barbara gordon i'm so
super excited i'm so excited for you to
come on the audio adventure with us only
on spotify joining the cast alongside
gina will be sam wittwer as the
harvester emmy raver lippman as kell
jessica marie garcia as renee montoya
and jim peary as arnold flass
hey dc fandom it's your boy winston duke
and i am so excited so honored to be
joining the dc family
with batman unburied with spotify and dc
and we have been cooking up something
very
very special for you we've been creating
something that's nuanced and beautiful
with great characters
great voices and just a beautiful
experience
so in that vein
i
am
batman
holy smokes batman
more news to come from spotify and the
forthcoming batman unburied podcast
still to come batman cape crusader
harley quinn and the first details on
the batgirl film
we know fans love one-of-a-kind
partnerships so we are here to announce
an exclusive collaboration between the
batman and puma here to tell us more
about it is none other than football
icon that's soccer to some of you and
our fellow brazilian neymad
now that is huge news
[Music]
from
come on be honest fans would buy
anything having to do with dc especially
if neymar is involved yeah you're not
wrong but now i want to talk about one
of my favorite gotham city girls barbara
gordon also known as batgirl the tech
savvy martial arts badass is getting her
very first full-length feature it was a
role that every actress in town wanted
but ultimately it went to leslie grace
after her stellar breakout performance
in last summer's in the heights she was
so good in that and now we're all
looking forward to seeing leslie take on
the bad guys in a very different version
of gotham city let's learn more about
batgirl in this dc spotlight
it's your girl leslie grace hi dc fandom
and i'm your new batgirl i don't know
about you guys but every step of this
process i'm like i can't believe this is
happening it's a big big honor and
privilege to be to be part of that world
that's really unbelievable i feel like a
kid again honestly i just feel like the
luckiest writer on earth
we wanted to have a very broad broad
casting it was very rarely rage of ages
and and races and what was important for
us it was that the best actress for uh
for the part would be cast so eventually
it's uh we saw leslie yeah among it was
a goosebump moment yeah i was really
like like the whole time who is gonna be
i mean there was something that you know
she just you know like that hit a nerve
and felt like okay we are we are
actually watching barbara golden
she's a girly girl but she also
is so capable of being strong and being
determined and like kicking butt and she
wants to prove herself but she's also
still just so sweet a lot of times we we
focus a lot on the uh on the male
superheroes but it was really exciting
to read for a female superhero that has
that grit and like is very sincere and
almost eager to prove herself what's
kind of fun about barbara and batgirl is
that in this story she's discovering
batgirl for the first time and so she's
getting to explore a duality she's
always had in her personality but this
whole new side of her personality is
slightly kind of
more daring slightly less law-abiding
side of her personality that we get to
just have fun and play with
we ask leslie to train a lot we want the
fights to be you know pretty realistic
so that it feels more raw and more real
and more relatable i'm really excited
about the action i mean i'm training so
hard and we're trying to get as much you
know learned in my body before i get
there so i'm excited about what that's
going to actually look like once we have
a suit and once we're on location
figuring out those fight sequences so
that's really exciting to me
you know i'm a fashion girl too so i'm
just dying i'm like looking at the
batgirl behind me and i'm like all right
i can see it we like that she has a call
that we can see she will have a call so
it's not it's not gonna be the design
with just the mask on the eyes it was so
funny it was one of the first questions
i asked once we were on i was like so is
she half is she gonna have red hair
because like i'm so ready
affirmative yeah
of course yeah there it is that girl is
gonna have everything in the moment
all the emotions yeah this is gonna be a
climax it's gonna go christian the
christian
can't wait
i'm so ready
while the batgirl film is just about to
begin production we don't have to wait
much longer to see how titans is going
to wrap up its season 3. standing by
right now we've got one of the casts
from tv's titans with some exciting news
and an exclusive look into the near
future
hey guys brenton thwaites here i play
dick grayson and nightwing in titans on
hbo max
um
we're very happy that you guys have been
enjoying season three we loved making it
and um it's good to know that it's
landing on audiences
especially the hardcore true nightwing
fans um titans fans
um
we're excited to be here at the dc
fandom
uh we're gonna debut an exclusive clip
from season three for you to see
um
and uh we really hope that finale um you
know packs the punch and kind of lands
for you guys
but first we're going to announce
something
we're going to announce something
mr honey we practiced this what are we
going to announce
season three
season
four we're gonna announce we're
announcing season four
um titans is gonna go again
and um we are very excited to go back to
canada and continue making this
wonderful show
uh it's been a wild ride i love making
it um toronto is a wonderful place to
work and this is such
great versatile diverse content to be
able to work on as an actor
but it is all thanks to you guys for you
know watching it and enjoying it and
demanding that they make another show
another season um
anyway we're out thank you see ya
[Music]
okay dick i'm here what do i do okay i
need you to connect the router to the
wayne manor mainframe slide the security
panel cover straight up
it should come right off
you should have told me about jason
would you have gone inside if i had
still should have told me
okay
got it okay hold on you're not done yet
[Music]
i'm going in
tell guard to cut the red wire and hook
it up to the router
the red wire you never cut the red wire
cut the red wire
guy it's me dick left
he said cut the red wire what
no you you never cut the red wire i know
but
that's what he said
what's happening
we're in
oh what
there's a security question
what's the name of the one who got away
joker
[Music]
riddler
oh
tim
i've got one more try at this where i'm
locked out
dry selena kyle
who's that
trust me
s-e-l-i-n-a
[Music]
welcome
who's selena kyle
it is now our privilege to introduce two
larger than life characters both have
amazing fighting skills but one has
equally impressive biting skills yeah
please welcome harley quinn and king
shark
oh hello
ladies gentlemen zays and gays fancy
meeting you here inside starro's a
b-hole
look we all know why i'm here okay to
present a little something something for
season three of my show which was
announced in like uh 1972 and here we
are in um 2021 and like two whole
generations of animators have been
burning the midnight oil on it and the
season is still not finished and those
poor artists died of a cute carpal
tunnel for nothing
sorry to interrupt are you still vamping
uh yes did you get the season three
footage from hbo max it is currently
being uploaded onto the fan dome server
and this is only happening now because
because the hard drive containing said
footage looked like a piece of sushi and
i ate said hard drive but it's being
uploaded it is so you passed the hard
drive the hard drive is wireless and it
is very much still inside is it high
speed oh my metabolism yes i'm lucky
oh look the producers are telling me
it's ready to go okay the moment we've
all been waiting for a sizzle reel for
harley quinn season three coming to hbo
max sometime in 2022. roll that
beautiful bean footage
i've always wanted to say that
so
what do we do now let the eat bang kill
tour begin come here
[Music]
i'll bring harley and ivy to justice and
then you'll change your team
i am here for reverend
hell
oh
i am
[Applause]
to us
together at last partners
[Music]
there are so many surprise twists and
turns and i say that as someone who's
already lived i will admit that looks
pretty great gonna be better you know
after the crayon guide you know colors
it in and then the sound effects guy
does the p2 stuff and you know the music
guide is the ban and then nothing with
the guitars oh god animation takes
forever
you're telling me
i'm sure they'll get around doing
something cool the old
k hombre
any minute now yeah don't worry you you
look you look great well there you have
it folks enjoy the rest of fandom i
guess and please remember all the cool
stuff you saw earlier and not
that and get ready for more of this soon
so i can move right now
not too shabby
oh okay we're done here
[Music]
huge super fan of all things you see and
a big thank you harley quinn and king
shark now that we know what is happening
with all of the other colorful
characters in gotham city it is time to
check in on the man himself the 1990s
award-winning show batman the animated
series was the first introduction to
this iconic character for many carried
batman fans sons were excited that
original series creator bruce team will
be teaming up with james talker and two
of the biggest names in television and
film jj abrams and madrid to reimagine
the series for a new generation let's
check in with that dynamic group and see
what they have planned for batman cape
crusader
i'm jj abrams exec producer of batman
cape crusader i'm bruce tim executive
producer of batman cape crusader hi i'm
matt reeves executive producer of batman
caped crusader hi i'm james tucker and i
am a co-producer on batman cape crusader
warren's animation asked if we would be
interested in working with bruce on a
new animated batman series and matt was
working on the batman film
so it just felt like an opportunity to
collaborate not just with bruce but one
of my best friends
on a project that i i knew would be
incredibly meaningful to all of us one
of my my elevator pitch versions of this
show is that it's it's more batman
animated series than batman animated
series it kind of goes back to the
original principles of the show that we
originally came up with back in the
early 90s there was certain limitations
on what we could do
in terms of adult content in terms of
violence and adult themes and my idea is
basically to say okay it's 1990 again i
get to do what i want to do this time
and i got jj and matt backing me up you
know in bruce's world in this new
iteration it it's just batman right now
there's not the justice league it
doesn't exist there aren't any other
superheroes it's batman you're watching
this lone figure swimming through the
cesspool of gotham it's batman alone
he's batman
i mean whether he's wearing the mask or
not he's batman and bruce wayne is the
mask bruce wayne is a phony person he's
a construction that batman has created
to deflect suspicion from his activities
so he's going to be very low-tech
initially you know as he develops as a
character we'll start introducing those
gadgets and you know the audience can
see how he developed the batmobile using
different prototypes that's part of the
fun of this series is we're finding him
discovering these things
that most other batman series
they already were there it really is an
incredibly complex psychological story
about someone who in a way needs to be
redeemed and that's kind of what at
least this first season's about we've
reconfigured some of the roles some of
the characters have we're starting
before batman has earned their trust and
they've earned batman's trust so there's
nothing assumed we don't know that
commissioner gordon will be batman's
ally the journey of the show is to see
how they you know eventually
grow together and learn to trust or not
you know not nothing is assumed in this
series as far as
um what we're used to seeing in the
world of batman what this does is it
gives us the opportunity to say okay
well the versions of joker and catwoman
and penguin those versions that we did
on batman animated series were really
great and iconic
but there's lots of different ways we
can take those characters that we
hopefully that we hope will be just as
iconic and just as powerful bruce
pitched the concept of caped crusader
and he had the strange days short that
was done for batman's 75th anniversary
that was very old school
film noir look it was in black and white
and i think that's what really closed
the deal on the pitch because um looking
at that they could see exactly what the
show was going to look like but just so
it's clear the show won't be in black
and white
unless i can talk bruce into doing a
special episode
this new iteration is very much born of
a noir sensibility definitely heavy on
the on the german expressionism film
noir kind of styling set in the kind of
timeless 40s world if anything we're
probably going to lean into that even
more in terms of authentic clothes and
hairstyles and hats and vehicles and
architecture the way we deal with
the characters uh
is going to be a quite a bit more modern
in terms of inclusivity uh
representation things like that cape
crusader is something that you know i
feel
uh honored to get to be part of
the creative conversations to get to
help and and support along with matt you
know the
not just the vision for how they want to
do it but but even
in using new technologies the
opportunity to take advantage of of
literally techniques that didn't exist
back when when bruce was doing the
animated series it's an honor and i'm
thrilled to be able to work on this but
to be honest with you the most exciting
part is i can't wait to see how it turns
out i can't wait to see all of this come
together i'm a fan and i just want to
see what bruce does
[Music]
even though it's still early days that
all sounds amazing but when cape
crusader will air on cartoon network and
hbo max i seriously can't wait for this
one either there's so much talent behind
this series and speaking of talent let's
take a look at your amazing gotham
inspired art
[Music]
wow i just love seeing your creations
don't forget jim lee will be announcing
the winner at the end of the show so
stay tuned to see if you've been chosen
do you like pizza have you ever wanted
to be like the batman then you will want
to get your tic tac on with those pizza
fanatics at little caesars who are
partnering with the batman film in
theaters in 2022. to get in on the fun
record how you would navigate your
everyday life if you were at the batman
then tag your video with hashtag be like
the batman on tick tock to learn more
check out at little caesar's pizza on
tick tock we won't keep you in the dark
and here's something else to be excited
about a new dc mobile game announcement
from ludia looks like the most iconic dc
superheroes and super villains are going
to be featured in a puzzle rpg mobile
gamers get your fingers ready for dc
heroes and builds
the interesting thing about power
is not whether it's used for good
or evil
nor is it that even the greatest power
can be lost in an instant
it's what we choose to do when
identities crumble
the line between hero and villain blurs
and extinction draws near
enter a crisis where sworn enemies will
be forced to unite
the fate of the universe
is in your hands
[Music]
we have some exciting news for fans of
collectibles here to tell us about it is
legendary comic book artist and founder
of mcfarland toys todd mcfarlane hey
thanks candace and hope you're enjoying
yourself and so are all the fans out
there today uh i'm here to talk to
everybody about mcfarland toys my
company and dc direct we just started a
partnership but basically i'm going to
take all the things that we're good at
and continue to do all the things that
dc direct has been doing so here's a
couple of things to look forward to
we're going to continue the batman black
and white series which is over 100
different statues already we're going to
do the harlequin red white and black
series we're going to continue doing the
dc designer series to look forward to
all of that this is just the beginning
right now one of the early statues we
want to announce is the joker purple
craze from the artist greg capullo who i
think is one of the best in the business
it comes from the pages of the batman
death of the family that both greg and
writer scott snyder popularized i've
been waiting a long time to finally get
to the batman movie and it's coming one
of the things we're going to be doing is
a big tall statue of the robert
patterson batman and it's based on the
concepts and the costume and the
reference that was given to us directly
from the producers and director so that
we're going to make it as authentic as
possible take a look at it it's going to
be super cool for your collection the
thing i'm looking forward to the most is
continuing the batman black and white
line it's the longest running statue
line that's been out there in
collectible history number 100 was based
on my artwork so that was kind of cool
this one is based on the artwork by mike
mcnula
this is from the graphic novel gotham by
gaslight uh written by brian augustine
we've done a couple other mike mcnulars
in the past in that series and they've
been some of the top sellers so this one
is not going to be any exception also
big news wouldn't be doing a giveaway on
the dc uh designer batman series uh this
one is gonna be based on the comic book
batman year two artwork by myself so i
know what it's supposed to look like and
on top of it i'm gonna sign that toy for
you so if you want a chance to win that
cool big batman head over to
dcfandome.com
for a sneak peek at some of the upcoming
collectibles that are coming out
including dwayne johnson has black adam
and a bunch of other cool stuff
still to come shazam fury of the gods
and the batman's new trailer debut
dc fans were not slowing down with all
these announcements and surprises now
going into its fourth season young
justice is a fan favorite series focused
on the covered up side of the tv
universe taking place on earth 16. it's
his fan favorite characters like super
boy miss martian zatanna beast boy and
more as they take on an ever evolving dc
universe and this you've seen you can
watch the first episode of the new
season for free after the show on
dcfandom.com but there's still so much
to come on in hall of heroes that you
may want to finish watching our show
before you jump over to watch them all
until then here's a sneak preview of
season 4 of young justice
the heroes of young justice have grown
into leaders
mcgann connor and garfield are on their
own and right now fighting bad guys is
the least of their worries at some point
we decide who we want to be no one on
the team is perfect you broke the rules
makes me want to break some rules too
and sometimes being a superhero isn't so
super at all there are some things you
just can never prepare for and
some things you can never get over what
do we do pull your energies into me the
heroes you love always fight for what's
right surrender or die
that was my favorite clipboard
this season they'll fight for something
more no more
no more meddling you'll all die today
and the choices they make we decide who
we want to be
man for a minute i thought i lost you
too we'll alter the dc universe forever
young justice phantoms now streaming
i like it
[Music]
dc fandom is the only place to be for
the latest and the greatest dc news and
upcoming projects i am terry lt am and
to say i'm thrilled to be here with the
best fans in the world is a complete
understatement this is beyond exciting
now up next another first the talented
and revolutionary writer director and
producer and vadi verne is officially
making her first show at hbo max eva has
joined force with writer roberto patino
to bring you dmz based on the comic of
the same name the show takes place in
the future where america is caught up in
the second civil war leaving manhattan
in ruins the resilience of community and
the human spirit is really what stands
out in these four parts limited series
starring rosario dawson and punjabi brat
now over to anthony roberto to hear more
[Applause]
hi i'm ava duvernay i'm roberto pitino
and we're here today to talk about our
hot new dc comic adaptation dmz it's a
story
about a fractured people that are coming
together where we have a civil war
between the free states of america and
the united states of america and our
story takes place eight years into that
dmz where the rule of law is basically
dictated by the most powerful person
at any point in time and that could
change from block to block so you have
people who are in the city who've
basically been abandoned and the big
kind of thrust of the story is an
outsider comes in and she turns
everything upside down and that
rollercoaster ride that adventure is one
of the things that i love most about
your script and one of the reasons why i
had to direct it had to be involved
let's talk a little bit about rosario
dawson and the character of alma alma
was inspired by one of the most
fascinating characters in the comic book
and also one of the most underserved
characters in the comic book named zee
who is this fearless medic i really took
the creative guard rails off
and
dove into the spirit of z and reinvented
her you know this show is a bit of an
origin story for one of the best
characters in the graphic novel she
comes out the other side with a whole
new understanding of what her place in
this world ought to be
i mean the thing is like a beautiful
chaotic messy
grappling with gender
and who can do what and what power looks
like and who really has the power this
is exemplified through parko played by
benjamin bratt and wilson played by
hoonly and these are two actors
roberto they came to play man parco
delgado is this guy who said you know
what i am the law i am the power here
and
who i am and what i say i am
no one's going to challenge me on that
if i say with enough resolve
wilson on the other hand is about the
opposite side of that where everybody
gets to make truly free choices in the
dmz they get to decide who they want to
be and the result of that is this
patchwork of gangs and tribes and
outfits
and wilson sees that as a marvel because
that's what the dmz is it is set in a
world that's just a few moments into the
future and it speculates what would we
be if we let the worst of our divisions
get to us i just think it's super cool
it's also important in ways that allow
us to consider ourselves now
and what we want to be going forward
we're just pleased and proud that it's
going to be making its way to hbo max
and you know it's just been a pleasure
working with you my friend i can't wait
to do it again and again indeed it's
been such a pleasure working with you
too and i honestly cannot wait for the
world to see dmz it's a world i'm i'm
thrilled to to share share with
audiences uh and especially with the dc
fans same here well thank you to uh dc
for having us and we'll see you on hbo
max very soon
dmz isn't the only dc project from the
brilliant ava duvernay she's also
bringing the fans naomi inspired by the
amazing dc comic of the same name from
writers brian michael bendis david
walker and artist jamal campbell naomi
stars this incredible actress casey
wallfall hi casey great to see you hi
candace it's so great to be here
everyone is so jazzed for naomi and i am
loving the diversity that's become the
norm in the dc universe how does it feel
to be a part of the dc family it's an
honor to be a part of the dc family i
for so long have watched shows like the
flash and a bunch of other dc tv and
movies so it's really special to me and
very full circle for me and everyone who
i've talked to within the dc universe
has been incredibly welcoming which
makes me really happy and it has been
it's been so exciting i'm really excited
for people to see this character that is
so special to them within the comics on
tv and since she's so fairly new to the
dc universe there's a lot of room to
grow within the character and within the
story and it's something that we haven't
seen yet within the dc universe how did
you prepare for the role of a teenage
superhero preparing for the role of a
teenage superhero isn't so hard for me
because i started the show when i was 16
naomi is 16 i'm 17 now so our lives they
often overlap as i'm reading the scripts
i get to pull from my family and my
friends and things that i'm going
through and when you're a teenager it's
really crucial when you're figuring out
your identity and who you are and what
you like and what you don't like which
is a lot of what goes through naomi's
head throughout the story it's a
superhero show but it's also a
coming-of-age story when it comes to the
part of preparing for the superhero part
i can't relate to the supernatural part
of the story but i can relate to being a
good person and doing good deeds which
is a huge part about being a superhero
and i've also read the comics when i
first booked the show i got the series
of the comics and i've also read the
justice leagues that she's in and i'm an
avid reader so getting into comics is
something that the show has started me
on what makes naomi different from the
other female superheroes out there well
as i said before she's a fairly new
superhero so there's a lot of room for
growth but honestly she's a young female
black teenage superhero which is really
special because that's something that we
rarely see a character have their own
comics and to have on tv and i think
what also sets her apart is her
character and her heart she's incredibly
confident she loves the people around
her she's incredibly driven incredibly
smart and isn't afraid to show it and
although there are a lot of naomi's and
people like naomi in real life those
aren't always shown on tv so i think
it'll be really special i also think
what makes it different is the unique
characters within the setting of the
show and the creatives in the team and
the crew and the cast they make it even
more special so i'm really excited for
people to see the show thanks casey
thanks so much for being here let's give
the fans a little teaser of what's
coming their way in this dc news flash
featuring naomi
now are we ready to begin
what's going on annabelle says there's a
stunt happening in the square
something to do with
superman
i need this for my site bathroom break
10 minutes i'll be right back
[Music]
uh
hi everyone i'm ask your angel i can't
believe i'm here in the hall of heroes
celebrating all things dc with you the
greatest fans in the entire multiverse
but i couldn't wait to tell you that we
just finished shooting the sequel to
probably your favorite dc movie of all
time featuring the only teenager to ever
take a subway ride to the rock of
eternity
philly's own billy batson the new movie
is called shazam
you see what i did there because in the
movie when he says anyway
i'm zachary levi and let me tell you
something our new movie shazam fury of
the gods is going to be out of this
world in fact the fate of philadelphia
and probably i don't know actually the
entire world is in uh
my hands but this time the family and i
we're up against some seriously scary
villains helen mirren and lucy liu my
real life alter ego asher angel and i we
had such a great time making this movie
with our director david sandberg and the
rest of our cast jack and megan and adam
and ross and grace and dj and ian and
jovan and faith there are so many and
like our new cast members like rachel
segler we just wanted to take you behind
the scenes to join in the fun during the
making of
shazam
[Music]
hello my name is zachary levi i should
have a little tag and i play shazam
we all established something very
special on the first movie and and
shazam fury of the gods we expand on
that
now they have to balance their life with
being superheroes this is where you hang
out with your superhero friends isn't it
these goddesses
come to our world
our incredible new villains
lucy lou and helen mirren
she's kick ass is calypso
we have mythological creatures minotaurs
harpies and dragons
when i talk about upgrades we got an
upgrade a huge upgrade in the suit
bigger action sequences bigger set
pieces we go from athens to philadelphia
we go from the rock of eternity and the
library of eternity to the realm of the
gods so we get to go to environments
that were never explored in the first
phone
we have it all three two one
shazam fury of the gods
[Music]
takes the excitement and the action
to a whole new level
it's going to be more of a spectacle
this fun all around
you're in store for a treat y'all
[Music]
you know it doesn't matter how many time
i yell the word sazam i still can't fly
i also never seem to turn into a
superhero um oh well i'll just keep
trying
all right guys let's keep the action
going wonder woman who's been having a
great year getting ready to celebrate
her 80th anniversary let's take a look
back at a few highlights from her
extraordinary story
[Music]
wonder woman is one of the original
superheroes she is a universal character
diana's values are built in her it's all
about love and compassion and humanity
and peace and inclusiveness
it's part of who she is then that's what
makes her so special
[Music]
shall we
she believes in good and her optimism
radiance hope to the world she's been
around because i think she struck a
chord at a certain time and then just
kind of evolved throughout the ages
we all were wonder woman on the
playground and i love that she elicits
that in people and makes people feel
like they could be wonder woman
we are so excited to get to be here and
get to talk about the spirit of wonder
woman when i think about myself as a
child
learning about the character and
watching linda and how much it meant to
me and how much it went on to mean to me
over the years you know getting to be a
part of the passing of the torch of this
amazing character into the world is
incredible it was a
a an honor to
and an excitement for me just to go to
see your movie patty
i know what it was like from the inside
out and
i know what
what the legacy meant to me and when i
created the character
it wasn't on the comic book page her
kindness and her goodness her strength
was lasso of truth and it was defensive
things
and
and that meant something to me because
we know
what wonder woman is
we we not just you and me but the women
out there and the and the women that
have come behind us and with us and
through us and i hope
that they can see
what that is in their own lives it gives
me sort of chills talking about it
beautifully sad linda it's so much more
than a comic book character it is an
idea and an essence and as a matter of
fact i wrote a song for you in for gal
and and uh based on an original lyric
that i had started for my husband but uh
when i did your movie
uh i i finished writing this uh song
that comes out in october actually
called human
and divine
and it's about the love of wonder woman
and i can't wait to hear it because it's
incredible and i'm so excited for it to
be heard by the world
um
here's the interesting thing i think
that wonder woman was controversial at
the time that she came out to my deep
surprise
she was controversial still when you did
it linda because i remember all of the
conversation about were you too
beautiful were you too kind were you too
loving interesting to me that even when
we made the film
it was still controversial that she
could be all of those things at once and
that to me is the essence of wonder
woman i find
ourselves
to be in such a lucky place in time
right now as it relates to wonder woman
because i actually think she is the most
relevant superhero of our times
because at this moment i think values
are incredibly important and the values
of being capable of doing more than
fight
and challenging self to be a superhero
of love compassion kindness goodness
patience
you know all of these things and be
willing to fight even physically to
stand up for those things is what
matters right now it is certainly not my
invention
or yours but
it feels like i'm a part of
something
and that we take on to the next
generation of fans and that is my hope
for the future certainly and your hope
for the future what you
uh in in wonder woman three which i
can't wait to hear you uh uh
come out with uh any you can't wait to
hear me not talk about
i can't wait to hear you not when we get
to this okay not talk about oh my god
not talk about
oh but it's coming everyone wonder woman
3 is coming and
and
even if i did know
you'd have to you'd have to kill me
to have me talk about it but i don't
thank you no we're super excited about
wonder woman three and uh
gal is so who's so bummed not to be here
who's the busiest person in the world
with now three
three little kids and shootings so she
was so bummed not to be able to be here
but we are all three
very excited about some exciting things
coming up with wonder woman three pretty
cool
who would have thought in my life at
this time in my life that this gift
would just
present itself to me and that's so cool
and that's what i'm hoping for all
of the fans of wonder woman and all of
the fans to know that your life is full
of surprises
and
the wonder woman in you
is
alive and well
[Music]
wow
i am just in awe of these women patty
and linda and to you the fans wonder
woman is all about celebrating the
strength and wonder in all of us and
creating a more respectful and open
world that's why we're so excited to
launch our new content series real
wonder with our partners at unilever
real wonder is a year-long celebration
of wonder woman's 80th anniversary and
together with dove we're committed to
creating and celebrating everyday women
who make the world a more beautiful and
confident place we'll share real world
stories by real women who are using
their everyday superpowers to help
create real wonder and change in their
communities we're looking for women who
aspire to ensure that the next
generation grows up helping young people
raise their self-esteem and realize
their full potential
check out the website below to nominate
someone who embodies celebrating the
wonder in all of us today
now let's take a look at a special
collection of fan art that celebrates
the icon on her 80th anniversary here
are just some of the truly wonderful
creation sent in by the fans of the
original the most genuine the pop
culture icon that is wonder woman
[Music]
[Applause]
i am always in awe of your amazing works
of art we as members of our dc family
why wonder woman has been such an
important icon for 80 years and what
wonder means to them let's take a look
i think it's about time that we realize
that women actually are half of the
human race and can be as strong and as
exciting and interesting and complex as
male characters
a character like wonder woman at the
time she was an incredibly you know
important
unheard of groundbreaking character that
i think has meant so much to so many
look it's wonder woman she's a standout
character among all the original pc
members i can't believe she's been
around for 80 years it's insane i think
she inspires everyone who aspires to be
like a strong powerful person
people gravitate towards her so much
because she's uniquely different i think
it's important to have strong female
role models like wonder woman because
women have gone through so much
adversity it is our sacred duty to
defend the world and it's what i'm going
to do it's important for little girls to
look up at the screen and see a hero
there and say i can be that i can do
that i am my own woman and i decide who
i want to be the inspiration that comes
from seeing this super strong super
smart elegant heroine
that stands on her own it gives them
someone to look up to even if it's just
in their imagination wonder woman is an
amazing character anybody can look up to
her regardless of status of course
wonder woman is really important to be a
role model for women and young women but
also for younger men it gives you like a
chance to believe that you can actually
be wonder woman that you can reach a
capacity of your dreams i suppose i
would say wonder inspires a sense of awe
wonder is the ability to still see the
grand and incredible things in the world
i love the hope behind the character it
is important to have these strong female
roles in society to show the power of
equality and to show that anything is
possible i think it's wonderful i think
there should be a million female
superheroes and i'm glad there are so
many now you know these women your
grandmother your mother your best friend
your aunt your teacher who are strong
capable wonderful women
strong women are very much a part of the
universe so of course we want to see
them reflected on the screen people like
wonder woman show us that every woman is
a queen every woman is a warrior every
woman is a fighter
[Music]
i think wonder woman is dope i like that
rope i don't understand it but it's cool
to continue the celebration of wonder we
have one more fun challenge now we all
know that part of wonder woman's iconic
lore especially from the tv series is
that she has the most awesome
transformation of any superhero with her
infamous skin
celebrate wonder woman's 80th with us by
doing the spin challenge on tick tock
show us how you spin into action and no
matter what the day brings you can spin
into anything that makes you take on the
day with confidence let me show you how
it's done
i am feeling very confident in my wonder
woman look
[Music]
and breaking news from dc publishing as
we are celebrating wonder woman and the
80th anniversary of this iconic
superhero we are also looking ahead to
2022 with trial of the amazons this
massive crossover event will affect the
future of the amazons diana has ascended
to a new place of existence fighting for
justice on a cosmic scale which has led
to massive change for the amazons queen
had palleted a parts for man's world
leaving nubia to watch over a themaskira
as new tribes of amazons appear yara
floor recently introduced to comics as
wonder girl and nubia find themselves at
the heart of a power struggle in this
historic story that fans won't want to
miss
[Music]
come on guys let's all put our hands
together for wonder woman's 80-year
legacy and you better believe this
really iconic character is not done
wowing us yet i'm such a big fan i've
already ordered a celebratory cake for
wonder woman's day on october 21st what
can i say i have a sweet tooth and
you'll have one too thanks to our next
segment based on the critically
acclaimed comic book series by jeff
lemire take a look
hello fellow hybrids and humans my name
is christian convery and i play gus on
sweet tooth i hope you are having the
sweetest time tuning into this year's dc
fandom
i'm excited to be with you all today and
answer some of your fan questions so
let's get started
the amount of pieces of candy i think i
ate
um probably about like more than 500
but i'm definitely not complaining that
was amazing i do have a sweet tooth in
real life too
so the ears are actually controlled
not in post-production and not by me
it's actually a whole rig that controls
them so it starts by me putting on a
skull cap which holds the wig and
antlers but the ears are actually
connected to that skull cap and the ears
have wires
that run down my neck and onto a pouch
on my back that's strapped onto me
and then there's a puppeteer and me and
him work together to remote control the
ears and think of cool ideas that we
could do during the scene to really make
gus come alive
are your ears soft
it's super
cool um my favorite part about shooting
in new zealand was how
the nature is so spectacular and
extravagant that when it's put onto
camera you're like is this fake because
it looks so majestic and magical that is
what i love about museum the magical
nature there
[Applause]
take me
i love
basically all dc characters i love all
the classics like for example superman
and
the flash but i gotta give to sweet
tooth because i am gus and gus isn't
sweet too then sweet tooth is the dc
comic book so it's pretty cool
getting to bring a dc comic book to
lights and being one of the characters
in
i indeed read the comics before starting
sweet tooth and i loved jeff lemire's
writing techniques and like how he
really
brought it alive off the page it's it's
so amazing the comic books and it really
helped me get a jump start with gus
what's in colorado
my mama
well i know that i'm itching to find out
what happens next but i really hope that
bobby's okay because
he's the cutest thing in the world right
well and of course all the other hybrids
but
you'll just have to wait and watch
season two to find out
[Music]
i absolutely love how much you guys
enjoy sweet tooth and cannot wait for
you to see what we have in store next
get ready for more banter hybrids and
candy to last you
a lifetime or at least to carry your
sweet tooth
see you soon for sweet tooth season two
[Music]
and now that we've satisfied your sweet
tooth there's a sweet deal waiting for
you over in the dc shop it's our final
exclusive drop of the day
this is the one that you've been waiting
for that's right it is time to scoop up
some brand new batman merchandise and
it's happening now at shop.dcomics.com
take a look
get ready for the world premiere of the
batman trailer
with all this talk about batman we must
not forget that much of the caped
crusader strength comes from something
other than his muscles or bruce wayne's
billions alfred pennyworth has always
been a huge source of support as both
batman's butler and feather figure
pennyworth the dc origin series answers
just that as it follows a young alfred
pennyworth who goes to work with
billionaire thomas wayne in 1960s london
let's take a closer look in this dc
spotlight
[Music]
hello dc fandom
we've had so much fun making pennyworth
over the past two seasons and we just
wanted to thank you all so much for your
support
on a personal note it's been a dream for
me to play this character and i really
will never forget it so thank you so
much
it sounds like you're saying goodbye
when actually we've got some really
exciting news to show haven't we so why
don't you
that is true i will
as you can see we're on set and we are
officially in production for season
three of pennyworth which is now a max
original series on hbo max that's right
and you'll be able to catch up on the
first two seasons of pennyworth on hbo
max early 2022 and the all-new season
three will premiere there later that
same year
we really can't thank you enough for
your love and support and it's because
of you the fans that we are back and we
can't wait for you to see what we have
in store season three we'll dive in
deeper in the lives of alfred martha
thomas beth sykes lucius fox and all the
other pennyworth characters as we find
out more about their involvement in the
evolution of the batman cannon and
there's a five-year time jump
all right that's a bit of a
spoiler well let's just say that there's
lots of exciting things happening on
pennyworth season three and we can't
wait for you to see it's going to be a
fun and revealing ride ahead we and
everyone here at pennyworth are so happy
to be back and we'll see you very soon
on hbo max
[Music]
all right so jim fans have noticed that
you've been posting some awesome artwork
leading up to dc fandom and we of course
have some very keen fans who are trying
to piece it all together see what it
might all mean so what can you tell us
yeah look um we wanted to create
something kind of fun for the fans to
engage with
it's essentially a puzzle
i've drawn 12 images each celebrating a
specific dc moment
we're revealing the final four right now
during fandom and so if you take all 16
and rearrange them
and kind of squint uh hopefully you will
see
um what we have been building up to and
uh it is the iconic cover from crisis on
infinite earths number one drawn by one
of my favorite cover artist george perez
and uh yeah it's a fantastic piece of
work and uh that is what this mosaic
approximates is squinting an official
instruction or rule to figuring out how
this all comes together absolutely
because look i i wanted to make it hard
enough so that people didn't immediately
recognize what the cover was so i
basically used elements and drew in
characters that approximated those
shapes and at the end of the day if you
again if you squint it should work um
but the uh dead giveaways are the panels
that say crisis on infinite earths and
we save them for this moment so that we
wouldn't spoil the the surprise or the
puzzle for the people that have been
working on it well it sounds really cool
and i am so excited to take a look at
this with all the fans watching right
now too it sounds like it took a while
to put this all together how long have
you been working on it yeah uh look you
know how slowly i draw so it's been uh
we've been working for a couple months
also i love that you're like you know
how long it takes me to if i tried to
draw anything near what you draw sure it
would be like three years and i'd have
like there's one line sure no it doesn't
look like anything tony look it wasn't
just a drawing i also had to make sure
that the drawing approximated this this
overall kind of iconic image right so
that was the challenge so now that we've
got some more revealed yeah what does it
all mean jim
yeah so that is the 64 000 question um
if i could date myself but then in a day
uh it is the
and uh
the the you know
so that the fans is
really easy
that's awesome but you do know that it's
not just you and i here talking there's
like literally millions of people
watching us right now
yeah um
yeah you know we'll we'll fix it in post
right is that what they do right yeah
yeah we will no problem we'll fix it in
post bleep everything all right so since
jim doesn't want to reveal all of the
secrets right now i think you gave the
fans some great stuff so they're gonna
come up with their own theories because
i know that's what we all like to do
um and speaking of fans let's pivot to
some other fans and amazing artists so
are you ready to reveal some of the
winners of the art contest yes uh look
um the
art contest was one of the most popular
items from fandom last year we repeated
it working with talent house we got a
ton of amazing submissions from artists
and creators all around the world
it is the hardest part of my job trying
to pick a winner
but we were able to settle on some some
pieces that were just stunning so let's
take a look at the winners
[Music]
all right i took a walk around the hall
of heroes and found a secret passageway
and i'm literally in the back cave guys
now if you're a dc super fan and i know
you are then the mere mention of the
batman give you chills up and down your
spine and i know you can't tell but
right now i'm doing backflips on the
inside
bat fans like myself have been waiting
impatiently for this one so without
further delay let's check in with matt
reeves robert pattinson and sir kravitz
for a look inside the production of this
much anticipated film
[Music]
for some reason batman just always stood
out
it's one of the major characters of the
20th century and so many people connect
it on such a deep level and for so many
different reasons
the first conversation i had with matt
about it i just knew there was something
radically different from anything we'd
seen about my movies before
[Music]
i felt that we'd seen lots of origin
stories we'd seen things go further and
further into fantasy
and i thought well one place we haven't
been
is grounding it the way that year one
does
to come right in to a young
batman not be an origin tale but refer
to his origins and shake into his core
right from the beginning there's a
desperation to it he's really working
out this rage all the fights seem very
personal
what's so wonderful about this world is
the exploration of the gray area
catwoman really wants to fight for those
who don't have someone else to fight for
them and that's where batman and her
really connect
he wants to inflict his kind of justice
he's just compelled to do it
there is no other option
[Music]
hey guys so you just saw the look of us
behind the scenes and um it feels like
that was forever ago which is really
strange and actually um as we're
finishing the movie now kind of really
emotional for me um to see you guys
especially uh
after everything that's happened and to
see you now again i feel like i've been
watching your faces every day
in editorial but now to actually see you
guys is really really great and um i
gotta say it was it was a an amazing
time making the movie with you guys and
um it's really cool to see you now oh
and it's so exciting to see like these
little snippets of the film you know
after for us being able to step away for
a while i know you've been in it the
whole time but every time i see just a
little bit it's just it's so exciting if
you can see the progression it kind of
seems like it's getting more exciting
and bigger and kind of
scary there was just something very
special and magical about
the way you guys played off of each
other right from the beginning and so i
just knew right away i was like going
wow there's just a really neat like i
know you guys are friends and so there
was a great chemistry right from the
beginning that i felt like there was a
connection which you naturally had and i
feel like when we were filming obviously
that came out more and more i mean do
you guys remember when we were doing
that that crazy uh
sort of i guess screen test i guess you
would call it you know when you guys get
together for the first time definitely
remember because that was basically my
audition right you know rob was already
cast and that was my audition and i was
really nervous and i remember you gave
me like a
the hardest part
to be honest with the helmet i have the
they were like here's this helmet you
know and you have to like walk out and
then you take the helmet off and you do
the scene but it's like sometimes really
hard to look like cool when you're
taking off like you get stuck and i was
like this is how i lose the part i lose
the part
because i can't take off a helmet
and it was just the opposite do you
remember your first day rob when you
were wearing
one of the actual bat suits when rob and
i first got together like we'd had all
those conversations and then just by
virtue of what it is it's batman the
studio's like well we always do like a
screen test which is so like you know
kind of the same thing you guys did rob
did first by himself and had literally
was wearing i believe val kilmers
that suit yeah which by the way like the
moment you put it on like that was kind
of a crazy moment
it was crazy but
but i remember putting it on and
thinking that this is impossible this is
going to be absolutely impossible i
remember you saying like
because
i guess just trying to move i mean
wearing
a kind of two-inch thick rubber suit or
latex suit and being
incredibly nervous and full of
adrenaline the whole time i remember we
did like two takes and then you were
just saying
what can we do about this sweat and i
was like nothing there's nothing that
can be done i have to be drained of
liquid
the other thing that i remember too
which is cool because it informed the
movie is at the end of that costume test
when you came and you put on the the eye
makeup and began the transformation
that moment for me that was when i was
like oh my god
it is so you like it was just such a
cool and i remember you as saying
afterwards to me you were like uh i
don't know what i just did i said it was
amazing which it was it was really
really cool i really did think oh my god
this version of this character this guy
who's sort of almost like if you think
of bruce wayne as like a recluse rock
star in a decaying manner there's this
part of me that so
saw you as that and i had no idea that
you would be interested in playing the
role at all i thought what if rob
doesn't want to play batman this will be
a disaster and then it turned out that
you completely
on your own had a whole path to the same
thing which is that you had been
obsessed with batman for years and when
you found out that we were doing this
version you were very interested so i
was it was one of those things that for
me felt really kind of lucky and faded
and then we met i really felt that
connection with you where i felt like oh
we're going to be able to find something
new with this guy and do something
really special but for me you were
always that version of what i saw in the
page and that was about trying to create
a new version of bruce he doesn't have
as much control over his personality
like the delineation between when he's
batman and when he's bruce is not so
clear and
other kind of um
iterations of it
you know he really knows what he's doing
when he's putting on
the cow and um i kind of really like
this idea it's a little bit out of
control he hasn't completely defined
what batman is i mean it's kind of he
gets lost in it whenever he's putting on
every night and it's kind of you're
basically
he's not sleeping and he's you know
becoming
this quite sort of odd creature like
just finding the right literally how to
move as batman how to talk as batman i
mean that was what was fun for me even
when you guys first met up i was like oh
so this is the rhythm of what it'll be
like when you guys
talk to each other like even something
as simple as that and like the way you
came in with like you had for me so you
had an attitude that was so selena right
from the way you came in i
obviously you know understand the
gravity of a character like this and
what she means to so many people but
what felt really important was to really
focus on the story that we're telling in
this moment you know and
um
you know try and create a real human
being you know i don't i don't want her
to be an idea you know i want her to be
a real human being
in a real situation in a real city
trying to survive and reacting to
her own pain you know and and her
history so
i really really focused on this
particular story and this particular
moment in this woman's life i think it
was about trying to find
a way again as zoey was saying to ground
her so that she felt like she had an
emotional journey that made sense for
who she was that ended up being selena
kyle but was one we hadn't seen before
and yet some ways it does connect to the
comics i mean that's the thing which
will be fun to share with an audience is
that there are very there are a lot of
iconic selena kyle aspects to the story
but i don't think any version of of any
of the batman stories that have done any
selena stuff have done it in this way
because this is the foundation that
we're setting right now right like as we
move forward and see her become catwoman
you know that heart and that humanity
will always be there
so we debuted our first trailer for our
movie last year at dc fandom and we
wanted to say thank you for the great
response it's only fitting that we share
the second trailer with you all today
okay enough from us
here's what you've been waiting so
patiently for it's the trailer for the
batman
police
hands up
[Music]
stay still
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
that's a warning
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
before the god
this is about a king
and rivers to match
i can take care of
myself if this continues it won't be
long before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for
oh you it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say thank you
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
what's black
and blue
and dead all over
i got you
so
[Music]
and that's the way to drop the mic and
end the show wow amazing on behalf of
warner brothers and dc thank you all for
watching this has been a super
experience it's been epic and all of us
at dc fandom want to thank you for your
unwavering passion for the dc brand and
of course for your continued love and
support thank you for being the best
fans in the world we hope you all felt
the love today on a global scale goodbye
from australia it was an absolute
pleasure bringing dc's multiverse into
your world be sure to check back in at
disneyfandom.com throughout the year for
breaking news on your favorite shows
films comics games and all the creative
geniuses behind them bye everyone stay
safe and stay super
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching thanks for
watching dc fandom
nothing compares to this well
truth is generations of fans across the
globe is who are here to celebrate today
my masterpiece
[Music]
fandom tides are changing that we take
on to the next generation of fans
[Music]
that's awesome
and at the end
i will admit that looks pretty great we
have it all and that includes you the
fans we're thanking all the fans love
you guys thanks for watching thanks for
watching thanks for watching
thanks for watching thanks for watching
thank you for watching thanks for
watching thanks for watching thanks for
watching thanks for watching
malo for watching
[Music]
okay we're done here
[Applause]
[Music]
you